All scripture is breathed out by God and
profitable for teaching, for reproof,
for correction, and for training in
righteousness, that the man of God may
be complete, equipped for every good
work. And thus, the reading of God's
holy and inspired word. What is up,
y'all? Warm welcome as always,
especially to those of you that might be
new. Maybe this is your first live
stream. You picked a good one. Maybe
this is your first time um being on the
platform. Period. So, if that's you,
extra special welcome. The Apostle Paul,
he told Pastor Timothy that the word of
God itself contains that which is
necessary for all doctrine, correction,
and training in righteousness. namely
that the man of God, meaning the pastor
in this case, has all that he needs
within scripture for all doctrine. It
will become increasingly obvious as to
why I started tonight's show with this
because tonight we are going to be doing
a deep dive on the great controversy
theme. Emphasis there on that word
theme. If you are a Christian and you
want to reach 7th Adventist with the
truth, it is imperative,
I mean an absolute must that you
understand tonight's topic. If there's
any topic to understand, it is this one.
The GCT is the world view, the world
view of Adventism. As you will see
momentarily, it was supposedly uniquely
given to the SDA church and only the SDA
church from God himself and is branded
as being the theory of everything, which
is equivalent to them having the God
particle.
The GCT is a set of lenses that color
the pages of reality and the way that
one sees the world as an Adventist. In
my opinion, really, it's this, not even
just the the 28 fundamental beliefs,
because those are filtered and distilled
down from this. This is what actually
makes somebody an Adventist. If somebody
has a great controversy worldview,
they're an Adventist. Uh because again,
all of scripture, everything is being
filtered through this extra biblical
lens. I would argue uh most Adventists
do not even know the movement has
equipped them with this filter that they
now operate with. Which is why there is
oftentimes a talking past one another,
if you will. The great controversy theme
is providing a set of presuppositions
that are unspoken and drive the end
results leading to fundamentally
different conclusions.
I have said on this platform many times
and will continue to do so. Not because
I want to be mean. Not because I want to
be a jerk. None of that. But truth
matters. Seventh Day Adventism is not
Christian.
It's not Christian. And the great
controversy theme is the foundation for
my claim. SDAs are going to take great
umbrage with this. I'm full aware. But
again, truth matters. And if they were
being forthright and shooting it
straight, they would say the same thing
about me. And I wouldn't be offended. I
would actually have a lot more respect
for them because then they'd be get, you
know, honest. Being a Christian is not
simply using Christianes, aka Christian
lingo and buzzwords.
What you mean by those words matters.
As we saw recently with the uh annual
council address from Ted Wilson, the SDA
church has a unique mission and purpose.
It's not the same as Christians who
share in the same God, gospel, and
mission regardless of what sort of
secondary doctrinal differences we may
have. We have unity in the gospel as
Paul exhorts believers to in Philippians
1, but the SDA church does not share in
that with us, which means they need to
be reached with the true Christ and his
gospel. They're an unreached people
group,
just like they see us as a mission
field, and we see them as such.
While the SDA church might use the same
language as Christians, they are
starting from a fundamentally different
place with a pre-earth origin story that
then interprets the scriptures in light
of that.
It's the starting point, not scripture.
The great controversy theme informs what
the SDA church believes about everything
from who Jesus is, the nature of God,
the gospel, salvation, atonement, and so
on.
Once that filter is then discarded, much
of the errors completely vanish. So if
you are a former Adventist, hopefully
tonight will also be beneficial for you
as both myself and my guests tonight are
very familiar with how difficult it is
to parse through the fog after leaving
this movement. Most of it is coming from
the great controversy theme. If you can
discard that, tons of other things will
leave. And in order to do that, you just
need to be reading the Bible.
But before getting into it, I want to
remind you folks that you can visit
answering adventism.com. I'm going to
make it quick because I got some stuff I
need to get into here before bringing
our guest in. And I want to go quick
because I want him to have plenty of
time. But I want you to go to answering
adventism.com. You can partner with us,
donate, access more resources, sign up
for our newsletter, access hundreds of
articles with uh easy to access source
documentation. Simply with a click,
it'll open in a new tab. It'll take you
right to the horse's own mouth. and many
many many more things. So go and check
out our website. Please utilize this
resource. It is a gift from us to the
Christian church as half of this battle
is raising the general level of
awareness amongst the body to protect it
from this sheep stealing organization
and its false gospel. So with that said
before I before I bring our guest in, he
will be doing most of the presenting
tonight. By the way, folks,
I want to lay the groundwork though for
some of what was said earlier by me, but
will also help in understanding what our
uh brother tonight is going to uh so
graciously explain. And we will continue
for years to come uh harp on this same
thing because it lays out uh for us the
horse's own mouth, so to speak, uh in
their own words better than any of us
tonight could. So, I say that because
we've looked at this resource before and
we're going to continue to. Um, it's
important to realize that the great
controversy theme is not identical with
merely the great controversy.
I've talked with countless former
Adventists who did not understand why
the word theme was being tacked onto
Ellen White's book title.
They did not realize that the theme
is the paradigm provided by the contents
of the book.
The theme is really a worldview that is
supplied by the substance of what's
found in there. So in the 2000 December
2000 issue of ministry magazine
publication for SDA clergy, one of the
SDA church's most impactful theologians
to date. Not Joe Schmo, not random SDA
guy online somewhere.
No, we're not saying he's infallible,
but if there's somebody qualified to
talk on this, it's Herb Douglas.
He spilled all the beans regarding what
the great controversy theme is and how
it functions for the SDA church. Notice
what he says, folks.
The link to this is in the description
box for those who want to follow along
and see it for yourselves. Okay,
starting on page five, his article in
the paper is titled The Great
Controversy Theme. what it means to
Adventists.
Quote, for Seventh Day Adventists, the
GCT is the core concept that brings
coherence to all biblical subjects.
Every philosophical or theological
system builds on a central governing
theme or paradigm. Its central theme
becomes that system's core truth and
determines all of that systems
principles and policies. Stephven
Hawking, the remarkable Cambridge
physicist, wrote in his 1988 book, A
Brief History of Time, that should
scientists discover the long sought
theory of everything, to explain the
varying mechanisms of the universe, we
should know the mind of God.
Seventh Day Adventists have been given
that, a perspective which provides a
theory of everything. It introduces us
to the mind of God. We didn't discover
it. It was given to us. We call it the
great controversy theme.
So get that. This is the core concept
for SDAs that brings coherence to all
biblical subjects. Not some, all.
What Adventists are taught by this
organization is a position that has been
filtered through this paradigm.
It's not just the Bible like, "Oh,
that's what the Bible just says," which
is how they oftentimes like to try and
position it. No, it's been filtered
through this.
The great controversy theme is
supposedly the equivalent of the God
particle, the long sought theory of
everything that people like Stephen
Hawking talked about. It explains the
varying mechanisms of the universe. And
to possess such a thing would be to know
the mind of God. He then states that the
SDA church possesses such a thing. They
didn't discover it because it was given
to them.
Given to them.
It did not come from reading the Bible.
It is something outside of that. And
they call it the great controversy
theme.
He continues,
"How we understand this core theme
directly affects how we grasp the intent
of the biblical writers when they used
words such as righteousness, salvation,
gospel, etc. The GCT helps us to work
our way through centuries of theological
confusion over the meaning of such
realities as justification,
sanctification, atonement, obedience,
and works. Without the GCT, all would
remain divided over such subjects as the
importance of the Old Testament
sanctuary service and the New Testament
view of Christ as our high priest,
mediator, the meaning of faith and
grace, the place of obedience in in
relation to legalism, why Jesus came the
first time, why he came the way he did,
and when he will return. Close quote.
So the GCT allows the SDA church to
understand what the biblical writers
really meant when they talked about
things like righteousness, salvation,
gospel, and so on. Everyone was
supposedly confused on all of this until
the SDA church came along. even though
you have division amongst them as to all
of these subjects.
But this is insight into the fact that
yes, the SDA church has a different
gospel as we will see momentarily
because the apostles were not preaching
this. They did not have great
controversy worldviews.
Yet, it's the great controversy theme
that is supposedly able to give you what
they truly meant when they talked about
things like salvation, atonement, etc.
You'll notice, too, the language around
these or the language around there being
division over subjects such as the Old
Testament sanctuary service and Jesus as
high priest mediator. This is just
language regarding the investigative
judgment and the sanctuary, something we
will get into later. But it's also
interesting to note that he includes
that it gives them the answer to when
Jesus will return, speaking to the idea
of imminence.
Yet their history is paved with false
prophecies about exactly that. Which is
why a regular question that I ask on
this platform,
why does the theory of everything
continue to produce erroneous and
divided results?
Nevertheless, understand that all of
Adventist theology is filtered with this
as the lens. You can't even understand
the Bible without it supposedly.
So, it's inconsistent for them to claim
that they only believe the Bible. No,
not possible in the system. He
continues,
quote, "The Adventist esqueological
framework sets us apart from every other
denomination that speaks of the end of
the world because it is governed by the
great controversy theme. The distinctly
adventist view,
distinctly Adventist view
is formed by a mutually supportive
cluster of ideas including conditional
immortality, 7th day sabotarianism, a
premillennial historicist esquetology,
acceptance of the gift of prophecy in
the ministry of Ellen White, teachings
about the priestly work of Christ in the
heavenly sanctuary, and a prepared
people by his grace. This mutually
supportive cluster of ideas that marks
Adventist esquetology exists today
because the great controversy theme
informs all areas of Adventist thought.
When the controversy is over,
the purpose of the gospel will be seen
as the vindication of the wisdom, power,
and love of God. Close quote.
Notice he admits that the GCT is what
sets Adventism apart from everyone else.
He specifically references esquetology,
but all of their theology is filtered
through this as esquetology is the
foundation in Adventism.
Which is why he says the GCT informs all
areas of Adventist thought.
That is another core difference by the
way between the Christian church and the
SDA movement. Our foundation is not
esquetology. Our entire framework is not
dependent upon every number, sign and
symbol being correct such that every
single hypothesis has to be true for the
entire structure to stand.
Yes, their entire system is built on
guesses that they think are infallible
because they've done or or because they
have this this God particle, but they're
in the same boat everyone else is,
except their foundation is built upon
hypotheses,
not the same foundation that the
apostles laid.
But this is what Mr. Douglas means when
he refers to mutually supportive
clusters, which we will look at tonight.
Now, let's look at the January 20, 1903
issue of the Advent Review and Sabbath
Herald. The then editor, er Palmer,
wrote an article regarding the great
controversy in Ellen White's writings.
Notice what he tells us.
quote, "I thank my heavenly father for
the interest that my brethren and
sisters have taken in the circulation of
Christ object lessons." That's an Ellen
White book. By the sale of this book,
great good has been accomplished and the
work should be continued.
But the efforts of our people should not
be confined to this one book. The work
of the Lord
includes more than one line of service.
Christ's object lessons
is to live and do its appointed work,
but not all the thought and effort of
God's people are to be given to its
circulation. Well, who's circulating
these books? Well, God's people. Oh,
right. So, the Adventists.
The larger books, Patriarchs and
Prophets, Great Controversy, and Desire
of Ages should be sold everywhere. These
books contain truth for this time. truth
that is to be proclaimed in all parts of
the world. Nothing is to hinder their
sale. Close quote.
So part of the work of the Lord in
Adventism is the distribution of Ellen
White's books.
I I just I imagine that. Imagine if I
went to church and they said, "Hey, it's
part of your obligation to the Lord to
distribute RC Sproul books."
What?
And it isn't to be contained to just
one, but many.
The thought and effort of Adventists is
to be given to other books, namely the
larger ones. Patriarchs and Prophets,
Great Controversy, and Desire of Ages.
And what do these books contain?
the truth for this time,
present truth.
So present truth, their favor or or
their their flavor of relative
progressive re revelation is also
necessary for all of this system to
work. That's another presupposition. You
have to have present truth.
Well, of course, because this same paper
tells you that the apostles didn't
preach this. Church fathers, they didn't
preach this. Medieval fathers didn't
preach this. Reformers didn't preach
this. Uniquely SDA,
he continues,
quote, Sister White is not the
originator of these books,
they contain the instruction that during
her life work, God has been giving her.
They contain the precious, comforting
light that God has graciously given his
servant to be given to the world.
ah getting into part of the SDA mission
from their pages. This light is to shine
into the hearts of men and women leading
them to the savior. The Lord has
declared that these books are to be
scattered throughout the world. Close
quote.
Ellen White is not the originator of the
books, which I would agree she was a
champion plagiarist, but that's not what
he means. He means they came from God.
Supposedly God was giving her this work
to do which apparently included
borrowing from other authors who
apparently God was also speaking through
since they were their thoughts, words,
ideas, etc.
Also remember
when Adventists try and and assure you
that they only believe the Bible and
that they don't esteem Ellen White's
writings to be equal with it. Not true.
Not at all. That individual may not do
that. But that person's not a mouthpiece
for the organization.
The reason scripture is authoritative
like it is is because of the source by
which it comes, God himself. It's his
word. There isn't a subordinate word
that he gives that's subservient to
something else he has said. If they're
both coming from the same wellspring, so
to speak,
then they are by virtue the same because
of the source that's providing it.
But we also here see a common claim that
you'll hear from them, such as the
current director of her estate, Dr.
Merlin Bert, who says, "These books
contain light from heaven that shines
into the hearts of men and women leading
them to Jesus, as we saw when we
responded to him some months ago. And
they love to try and cite second Peter
1:19 to support this.
They love to claim this is the purpose
of her writings and it's what sets her
apart from all the other false prophets.
She actually points to Jesus, not
herself or somewhere else. Keep this in
mind when we get into specifically who
the Adventist Jesus is. Okay. He
continues,
quote, "In the future, these books are
to make the gospel plain to many others,
revealing to them the way of salvation.
The Lord has sent his people much
instruction."
Again, who are his people? Adventists.
So, he sent them much instruction. Line
upon line, precept upon precept, here a
little, there a little. Little heed is
given to the Bible. And the Lord has
given the lesser light to lead men and
women to the greater light.
Oh, how much good would be accomplished
if the books containing this light were
read with a determination to carry out
the principles they contain.
There would be a thousand greater
vigilance, a thousandfold more
self-denial and resolute effort, and
many more would now be rejoicing in the
light of present truth. Close quote.
So, it is Ellen White's writings
to make plain the way of salvation.
They are what supposedly make the gospel
plain, just like Ted kept saying in the
annual council address, equating the
unique SDA message with salvation.
We see their other favorite buzz phrase,
which is that Ellen White's writings are
the lesser light that lead and point to
the greater light, which makes
absolutely no sense considering I don't
need a flashlight when the sun is out.
The reality is Mrs. White and her
writings function as the interpretive
guide in this movement as her and her
writings are also tightly wrapped up in
the GCT as you will see later. He
continues, quote, "Let no one think that
he is at liberty to fold his hands and
do nothing.
That anyone can be saved in indolence
and inactivity in an is or or to think
that anyone can be saved in indolence
and inactivity is an utter
impossibility.
Think of what Christ accomplished during
his earthly ministry. How earnest, how
untiring were his efforts. He allowed
nothing to turn him aside from the work
given him. Close quote. So, did you get
that?
Mr. Palmer speaking to SDAs
says no one is at liberty to fold their
hands and do nothing. What
did he What was he saying this in the
context of
distributing Mrs. White's books?
Not just one such as Christ object
lessons,
but the big conflict of the ages series
books
that anyone can be saved in indolence
and inactivity is an utter
impossibility.
Wow.
Your salvation is tied to distributing
Ellen White's books
and using how much Christ God incarnate
accomplished in his mission by God the
Father.
You better get busy
because he allowed nothing to turn the
work he was giving or to turn from the
work he was giving. Sorry.
So just like the second person of the
triune God incarnated and redeemed the
creation submitting to the father's will
perfectly. So you must distribute Ellen
White's writings because that's the work
given to you.
Unreal.
Now notice one quote before we bring our
guest in from Ellen White herself as it
pertains to the books that Mr. Palmer
mentioned. We've looked at this quote
before.
Selected messages, book three, page 122.
Quote,
"How many have read carefully Patriarchs
and Prophets, Great Controversy, and
Desire of Ages?
I wish all to understand that my
confidence in the light that God has
given stands firm because I know that
the Holy Spirit's power magnified the
truth and made it honorable, saying,
"This is the way. Walk ye in it." In my
books, the truth is stated, barricaded
by a thus saith the Lord.
The Holy Spirit traced these truths upon
my heart and mind as indelibly as the
law was traced by the finger of God upon
the tables of stone which are now in the
ark to be brought forth in the great day
when sentence will be pronounced against
every evil seducing science produced by
the father of lies. Close quote.
So there you go. her books barricaded by
a thus saith the Lord. Great controversy
included,
which is what the great controversy
theme is built off of.
Does it get much clearer than that?
Herb Douglas, the movement's foremost
theologian to date, arguably
the then editor of one of their official
organs, er Palmer, and Ellen White
herself, very clearly telling us that
this stuff came to the SDA church by way
of God, supposedly using Ellen White as
the conduit.
It is the equivalent of having the mind
of God and the theory of everything.
Only the SDA church has this. It was
uniquely given to them and only them.
Not the apostles, not the church
fathers, not the medieval church, not
the reformers, not the church in the
east, only them.
Distributing this message is the message
of salvation. It informs all areas of
Adventist thought and theology. It
supposedly brings complete coherence to
all of the Bible and settles age-old
theological debates.
One must not sit idle and not distribute
Ellen White's writings. Hence why you
see mass compa campaigns within the SDA
church to do such. And if you don't, you
aren't doing what God's given work is
part of.
They are not of Ellen White's origin,
but God-given, barricaded by a thus
sayaith the Lord, which means the SDA
Adventist system is supposedly
bulletproof.
Not a single error because it is a
direct revelation from God given to them
to correct uh all theological matters.
It has given them the correct
understanding of all of theology.
Yet Adventists wonder why we are
critical of this movement.
No one else is making these claims,
friends.
No one else is saying these crazy
claims.
When you make such claims, you bet
you're going to be analyzed
hyperritically.
It is such a grandiose claim to be
making.
But this is the worldview of 7th Day
Adventism and what makes them entirely
other than the Christian church. Not
because they're bad people, not because
we're arbitrarily trying to pick on
Adventists. It's simply the facts of the
matter. And being able to grapple with
this is what will allow you to navigate
through the theological fog. Whether as
a Christian seeking to reach SDAs with
the truth, as a former Adventist trying
to navigate yourself after leaving, and
even as an Adventist who may not even
understand because you haven't dove into
the deep end of the Adventist pool.
Tonight, you are going to need strong
lungs because we are going deep.
Christians, this is what the Adventist
mind is being bombarded with and shaped
by.
It's this that acts as the glue that
binds SDAs together. regardless of where
they're at on the spectrum.
Because despite Mr. Douglas assuring us
that the GCT is the antidote to
theological division,
Adventists are most certainly a divided
bunch,
as we also saw in Ted Wilson's annual
council speech. But with all this in
mind, now let's dive deeper into some of
this, such as the mutually supportive
clusters that he mentioned, some of the
pre-earth origin story narrative, and
what all this system considers to be the
gospel. Because yes, when the SDA church
uses the term gospel, they do not mean
the same thing that Christians do. They
mean the SDA system of theology, all of
it.
So, with me tonight is no stranger to
the platform, former Adventist, brother,
friend, Mr. CNB, the ambassador. Bro,
thank you for being here.
What's up, brother? How you doing? Uh,
grace and peace to the chat. How y'all
feeling tonight? Uh, hope y'all doing
pretty good.
Yes, sir. Always good to have you here.
The floor is now yours, my friend. And I
will chime in periodically. Um, but do
your thing, my man. audience, keep in
mind what I just said tonight as we go
through the presentation tonight. Like I
said, he will be doing the majority of
the uh presenting tonight. So, with that
in mind, brother, the floor is yours.
All right, family. What's up, man? I
just wanted to uh send greetings to
everybody uh for and for thankful for
those uh for being on the chat platform.
First of all, uh Miles, thank you for
opening it up uh for me again. Uh thank
you, thank you, thank you. And also for
the people in the chat that are here, I
see Nate 2D2, the great 2B2. Uh he's mod
of the month every month on everybody's
channel. I see Joey for all the way from
the UK. I see a lot of people uh that
have come to support both of us and uh
uh get this thing going. So, uh God
bless you all for doing that. Um I got a
couple people uh watching as well too.
Test the profit. So, shout out to you,
bro. Um welcome to you and everybody
that's here. So, much love to everyone.
Um, and yeah, so I wanted to get right
into this stuff tonight. Um, I'm going
to just turn my volume up on my thing.
There we go. All right. Yeah. So, um,
when we're looking at, uh, a mutually
supportive cluster, this is the wording
that was used in Dr. Douglas's paper um,
or article in the Ministry magazine. So,
uh again it make sure that you can you
can download these things for uh free um
the PDF copies for absolutely no cost um
from um ministrymagazine.org. You just
type in great controversy theme or Herb
Douglas um you know uh the name of the
uh the great controversy theme is the
title I think of the article um December
2000. So look that up and then you can
uh download it for free. Okay. Uh so
please feel free. So again, a mutually
supportive cluster. Um and we're really
talking about the SDA pillar doctrines.
Okay, the SDA pillar doctrines. These
are the things that hold up SDA
theology. Um and Herb Douglas is
absolutely correct that if they are
mutually supportive, it's not a
three-legged stool necessarily. It is a
seven-legged stool, but it's the same
thing. If you take away one leg off of a
three-legged stool, the whole thing
collapses. All right. Um I've said it
before on my um platform. I said it
again. Um any place I go that uh the 7th
day Adventism uh the the ideology, the
worldview, uh the theology, it is a
theological house of cards. All right?
If one thing drops, the whole thing
drops. Okay? And we're going to be
looking at that tonight. Um just based
on uh what uh Dr. Douglas has said in
his article um and uh please keep in
mind actually that this um m ministry um
it's for clergy all right so this
informs clergy who then inform us right
informed us I was I was very much in uh
7th day Adventist uh uh at in the year
2000 and of course it didn't just pop up
then this was from before um and I
remember GC in 2000 if I remember
correctly was in Toronto um which is my
hometown um but yeah that is um that was
a interesting uh uh uh pillar of events
that happened. But anyway, here we go.
Uh mutually supportive cluster. So we
got seven pillars. Okay. Um we have the
health message, the state of the dead,
uh the spirit of prophecy, number three,
the sanctuary, number four, the law of
God, uh number five, number six, victory
over sin and righteousness by faith.
Now, for those who um look at this and
say, "Well, I mean, it could be all
right." um they're they're kind of we
have to decode these things just a bit.
All right? So, when we're talking about
7th Day Adventist doctrine, a lot of
times we're going to have some terms
that we'll call double speak. Um what is
said is often not what is meant. Okay?
Um what is said is not what's implied.
Sometimes it could be something
completely different, something
something similar. So, we'll look at
that. Um we'll provide uh the evidence
for you, okay? Um as well as well. And
of course, as always, we got the
receipts there um to to back it up. So
you guys just make sure you check this
out. Um watch this stream again, uh take
notes, you know what I mean? Uh
screenshot all that stuff. Okay, so
here's what what we mean by decoding it.
The health message is actually what um
Dr. Douglas calls in his article a
prepared people. Okay. Um the state of
the dead is what he calls a conditional
immortality. The mutually supportive
cluster of uh of of uh events here.
Okay. Spirit of prophecy of course as we
know is Mrs. White. Um the sanctuary
1844 and the investigative judgment or J
uh the law of God. It really they don't
mean the whole law. They are talking
about specifically the ten commandments
and more specifically than that the
Sabbath, right? Um and then victory over
sin. actually sinless perfection. Um
some people you'll uh SDS will argue
with you. Oh, we don't teach sinless
pers per perfection. Um you kind of do
and they'll try to hide it, you know, uh
with some other things that we'll get to
uh tonight um in the guise of
righteousness by faith, but we'll get
there. Um and of course that's number
seven, righteousness by faith uh for the
purpose of the law of lawkeeping. Okay,
so that's a an incomplete sentence right
there. Righteousness by faith. All
right. So, uh, let's go ahead and take a
look at a couple of these things. So,
let's break it on down, y'all. All
right. Uh, so prepared people, the
health message, right? And of course,
when we're talking about the health
message in 7th Day Adventism, most
people know SDASism as the people that
will promote vegetarianism. Yeah. So, we
got some fry patch, got some leanies,
got some wham. Um, for those uh who have
never heard of these things before,
this is my childhood right here. Right.
So, um we uh we at my family growing up,
we were um meat eaters. We weren't uh se
we weren't um pardon me, we weren't uh
uh vegetarians, right? Um but it was it
was kind of weird, but it was a treat,
you know, like whenever we had potluck
at church to have veggie meat cuz like
it was exotic, right?
Doesn't always make a lot of sense to
people outside the uh the faith, but um
yeah, that was our thing. You know what
I'm saying? Uh Miles, you want to jump
in, brother? Exotic is one way to put
it,
right?
So, yeah, man. This is this was
something new. Like, you know, you could
have chicken. I don't want chicken. I
want to try the fire pad, sir.
Like, snap.
We're not going to actually have hast
stacks. We're having something else.
Right. Right. So, yeah, this is good
stuff, man. Um, but yeah, that's what it
what it means, right? And of course, uh
what we call Oh, I don't have my um
thing yet. Mouse. There you go. Okay.
Uh, everyone's favorite 30 plus
ingredient vegetable comfort food uh, as
they described it was hot dog substitute
was Big Franks. Yes. And 30 plus
ingredients for real, right?
Rio says veggie curry goat. Yes,
exactly.
Right. So, um, yes, 30 plus ingredients.
And this is marketed as health food uh,
for some people, but really uh, they
ask, and this is on their website, the
Lumol Linda website here. Um, is it
healthy? Well, it's vegetable comfort
food is what they answer the question.
So, it's not really healthy, but uh you
can enjoy it if you like, but it's it's
comfort food. It reminds you of the the
the leaks and the garlic from Egypt, you
know.
Yes, Gina Selena says, "Hot dogs in a
can. Veggie hot dogs in a can in brine."
So, and God bless you on that. Yes, a
prepared people. But what are we worried
about? you know, um it's really about
health reform. Okay. Um it's about
health reform and it's important. Um and
the question that people will often say
and will say, "Well, we don't teach it.
It's a it's salvific." Well, is it kind
of we'll let Ellen and other people
answer this question. Okay, so here's
Sister White. Um the uh my slides I got
to Okay, let's do that. Um so this is uh
you can see the reference here on the
screen says quote when properly
conducted the health work is an entering
wedge making a way for other truths to
reach the heart. Okay an entering wedge.
This is one way to get in. All right. Um
when the third angel's message is
received in its fullness, health reform
will be given its place in the councils
of the conference in the work of the
church and in the home at the table and
in all the household arrangements. Then
the right arm which is of course the uh
health message will serve and protect
the body. Um she said that this the if
I'm quoting correctly that the right arm
of the uh the three third angel's
message is the uh uh the health message.
Okay. So promoting vegetarianism,
promoting um veganism even at one some
point in the future, right? Um you can
see the reference here from councils on
diets and food. Um so those kinds of
things uh it's it's extremely important.
All right. Um but and it's an entering
wedge. And one thing I'll say uh before
you went to chime in miles um is that
when I was uh was wanting to sell uh
some books like in I think it was the
Canada youth challenge I think it was
called. Um when I was doing that um I
needed a summer job and so I was going
to sell uh some of the the books and the
goal was always to get a great
controversy in their hand was what they
told us right um so we would start off
oftent times with um a cookbook you know
so if you come to the door you knock on
the door and you know maybe it's a mom
at home or something like that and the
kids are there um oh yeah you want a
healthy meals and stop smoking program
and this that and the third and you want
to use that as a means to an end sooner
or later you're going to try and push um
the create controversy on them. So,
obviously, you'd offer, you know, the
kids books um first um and or the
cookbook and then use that as a means to
get in uh the place where you can get um
a great controversy or something like
that in their hands. You know, at least
Desire of Ages, they said, but you
really want to get a great controversy
in. So, yeah, go ahead, brother. Um if
you want to jump in. I was just going to
say that, you know, Ted Wilson in his
annual council address here last week um
made sure to make it a point, you know,
folks, we don't we don't teach that
diet, you know, you're saved by diet. Um
folks, we we looked at that on there and
that was only a handful of quotes. We
could have gone on and on and on. I'll
plug Monday's video. It has to do with
uh this same sort of vein um to some
degree, but nevertheless, um it it 100%
does. Um she says that if you don't
follow this message, it will blunt your
mind to the truths of God and um the the
gospel and you won't be able to accept
um really what she means is the SDA
message.
Um because this is is like you mentioned
uh I think you just slightly misspoke,
but you meant that it's the right arm of
the gospel.
She said that the the the health message
is the right arm of the gospel. It is
the third angel's message in varity.
Yeah, there you go. And that it's this.
That's why so many people know, well,
they typically go to church on Saturdays
and they're vegetarians. Well, right,
because that's the third angel's message
that they think that they're heralding
right now. And those are the two biggest
gateways for them to then proitize and
sheep steel to then get people to come
into the organization. They hold these
hell seminars. Um it's always about,
well, what about the Sabbath? What about
the Sabbath? They want to go to Bible
studies and start proitizing the seventh
day Sabbath, that sort of thing. So, um,
yeah, continue.
Yeah, good stuff. Yeah, no problem. Um,
yeah, so we're going to look at a couple
more quotes here and go to the next, uh,
pillar. All right. Um, so
there we go. All right. God demands that
the appetite be cleansed and that
self-denial be practiced in regard to
those things which are not good. This is
a work that will have to be done before
his people can stand before him, a
perfected people. Y'all catch that? Same
book, page 381. All right. God demands
the appetite be cleansed. This is a work
that will have to be done before his
people can stand before him, a perfected
people. So you tell me, is is this
offering uh a salvific um version of
vegetarianism or the health message?
Okay, you have to answer that question.
This is what she's saying. Okay, and
again, if you want to complain about it
being out of context, there's a context
for you right there, page number. Go
check it out and respond. Okay. All
right. Moving on. Ellen White again.
Those who indulge in meat eating, tea
drinking, and gluttony are sewing seeds
for a harvest of pain and death. The
unhelpful food placed in the stomach
strengthens the appetites that war
against the soul, developing, listen
y'all, the lower propensities.
A diet of flesh meat tends to develop
animalism. Hello. A development of
animalism lessens spirituality,
rendering the mind incapable of
understanding truth. Listen,
if I can't understand truth, can I
really be saved?
H if I can't understand truth, right,
can I really understand? Right. Right.
Right. Right. Am I going to be am I
going to slide in the back door into
heaven? Like how's that working? You
know what I mean? Going to default? I'm
going to slide, you know, slip in,
accidentally get saved. Like, what is
this, you know? Um, and again, it's it's
talking about, you know, a diet of
flesh. Look at the the the progression.
A diet of flesh tends to develop
animalism, and animalism based on a diet
of flesh, right, lessens spirituality,
rendering the mind incapable of
understanding truth. This is her words,
not mine.
Well, yeah. Yeah. And this just gets at
again, it's in the same book. I think
it's on page 80 um or 72. Um you've got
stuff in evangelism. You've got stuff in
medical ministry. I mean, she's saying
this same thing over and over and over
again. It stimulates the lower passions.
That's the other term that she would use
for this, the lower passions. Um that it
would essentially you are what you eat
type thing where if you eat a beast, um
you know, you'll become a beast.
Uh and that God's law is written on
every fiber of a person's being
including their nerves. um their
physical makeup and that to to go
against that is to go against the law of
God, all sorts of stuff. So,
um over and over again, it'll blunt your
mind. It'll keep you from being able to
understand truth, etc.
Which I'm still asking the question, uh
why hasn't uh Weimar been able to
substantiate these claims,
right? Right. And you think Lomolinda,
they have the theory of everything,
right? Right. Right. And you know,
Lomolinda is one of the largest uh you
know, research hospitals on the planet.
You know what I mean? Um, you think
there'd be more
uh more uh groundbreaking information,
but I ain't seen it. So, anyway, right,
a prepared people, right? Um,
conditional immortality. Okay. Uh, state
of the dead, aka soul death. Uh, Miles
and I had a friendly back and forth
about this. I was talking about soul
sleep, uh, which is the the term that
some people outside of SDA circles would
use, soul sleep or soul death. Um, and
Miles actually, um, if you can pop pop
back in what I don't know what shows
you, I know you've done a couple shows,
but, um, if you can kind of direct the
people to some of the shows that you
actually, uh, break this down on, you
know, um, I know the titles uh, could be
helpful for those that want to go back
into the archives and check it out.
Yeah, just type in on the website on
answering aism.com, just type in nature
of man and we talk about it on there. um
it's a more accurate term to what
they're saying because there's nothing
that's actually asleep a a conscious
entity sleeps.
Um that sleep is something that a living
thing does.
Yeah.
Um and so because what they're actually
teaching is that the soul ceases to
exist because the soul is they love that
analogy of the board and the the nails
that if you have you have a pile of wood
and a pile of nails, but if you put the
two together, you get a box. But if you
take those nails apart from the wood,
then you no longer have the box. Well,
the soul is supposed to be the box. It's
the combination of the body and breath.
And when you remove those two, um, the
soul no longer exists essentially.
So, uh, the spirit's the breath of life.
And then obviously you have the body.
And when those two come together, they
make the living soul, so to speak. So
soul death is really a more accurate
term.
Gotcha. You got you got a better analogy
than I got. I got the the math formula.
You know, body plus breath equals uh
living soul,
right?
All right. Um and real quick, I want
just going to address this. Um I see it
in the chat here. Adam and Eve says,
"Now I can say the scriptures um speaks
of not eating too much meat." Yeah.
Well, I mean, one of the fruit of the
spirit is um is temperance, right? Um or
self-control. So, yeah, too much of
anything isn't good. You know what I
mean? So, I agree with you 100% on that.
So, yeah. So, conditional immortality.
Okay. And again, these are conditional
these are pillars that have to rely on
one another. Okay. Um, so some of you
all are familiar with these things. Are
the dead really dead? Um, that's a good
Doug Bachelor amazing facts lesson. You
know, misinterpreted text on the state
of the dead. Um, you know, Pastor Steven
Boore uh as well too. So, some of these
SDA heavyweights are used to um we've
seen these before. Okay. But again, uh
these are um required uh soul death if
you will, soul sleep, um or the state of
the dead is a pillar doctrine because if
you if the dead um the righteous dead
are in heaven um elsewhere um or per
purgatory or anything of the sort,
there's no need for an investigative
judgment, right? And everything
collapses. Okay? Um, and same thing what
Elomite said. If there's a prepared
people and this is based on their diets
and everything else like that, if you
take that away, then what's the point of
having the right arm of the of the
gospel, right? And the third angel's
message starts to collapse. You know,
this this is why they're mutually
supportive cluster of of uh of of things
here, guys. Okay, so moving on. Mrs.
White says in the great controversy uh
through the two great errors, the
immortality of the soul and Sunday
sacredness, um Satan will bring the
people under his deceptions. And while
the former lays the foundation of
spiritualism, the latter creates a bond
of sympathy with Rome. The Protestants
of the United States will be foremost in
stretching their hands across the Gulf.
I love that. uh to grasp the hand of
spiritualism. They will reach over the
abyss to clasp hands with the Roman
power. And under the influence of this
three-fold union, the country will
follow in the steps of Rome in trampling
the rights of conscience. And shout out
to the BK apologist, my brother from
another mother. Uh missed him in the uh
in Detroit this past weekend at the
Contenders Conference. So uh please uh
check his channel out on Friday for a
recap. All right. So anyway, um yeah,
two great errors, the immortality of the
soul and Sunday sacredness. So these two
kind of go hand in hand together. Um but
again, we're talking about the mutually
supportive cluster. So if the uh soul
survives the body at death, what's the
point of the investigative judgment,
right? And you can't have it. It won't
make any sense, right? Um feel free to
jump in there, Mouse. Yeah, I was just
going to say that uh they don't even
understand what they criticize here on
both of these topics. They love talking
about and think they have the home run
arguments when it comes to um Sunday
sacredness, which I would argue the vast
majority of Christians today don't even
hold to um though they they I would say
that there are some who um
or or to some degree like all Christians
are are viewing it as distinct and
different than other days because it's
the day that the church gathers. Um, but
then there are some of us in the camp of
uh still being first day sabotarians,
but it's not at all like what the SDA
church posits.
So, it's a very small minority in that
regard. But even then, they don't
understand why Christians actually go to
church on Sunday because even then, both
camps, whether you're a sabotarian, a
first day sabotarian, or a
non-sabotarian, we still agree on the
foundation of why we're doing what we're
doing. So, they don't understand that.
They don't understand why we do it. It's
all conspiracies. It's, oh, it's because
the Pope. It's because the Council of
Leadyia. It's because of Constantine,
right?
It's because of Romanism. It's because
Daniel prophesied that the Pope would
change times and laws. Well, no. That's
coming from the great controversy theme.
The text does not say that. You're just
asserting this. Um, but nevertheless,
they don't understand again the second
one, immortality of the soul. They straw
man. We just looked at this a couple
weeks ago, folks, or last week, I should
say. Um, with Walter or or yeah, I guess
it was two weeks ago. Um Walter
Vice,
he's going on about about natural
immortality. And what he defines it as
Christians don't believe that.
Christians don't believe that all people
just naturally have immortality by
virtue of being a human. Christians
believe, and we looked at Irenaeus for a
quote on this, and we could have looked
at tons of others. It's just to show
that this is what Christians have
believed for almost 2,000 years at this
point.
It's that God sustains the souls. He's
the only one that has natural
immortality. He had no beginning and no
end. No one else has that. Christians
don't believe that by virtue of being a
human being, you're like equal with God
that you just have some sort of
immortality. No. God is the one keeping
your heart beating. He's keeping you
alive, both physical and spiritual.
So, we don't believe anyone has natural
immortality by virtue of just existing.
We believe that God sustains the souls
of people. They'll either be in paradise
with him because they'll be attached to
him and united to him, the source of all
good, joy, peace, etc. or they will be
cut off from him where right now in this
life there's a level of what we would
call common grace that's extended to all
people. God causes the sun to rise on
the wicked and the just.
Amen.
Uh he he puts breath in the lungs of
those who continue sinning, etc. that's
going to be cut off at a certain point
and then you'll pay the penalty for for
your sin and God will take away that
common grace but your soul will still be
sustained by God.
So it's not this idea of of natural
immortality which is again the pro the
understanding they have to have for this
whole thing to work as well. It's not
just that oh well they we believe in
conditional immortality. Well, no. You
also believe it based on a false premise
of what Christians actually believe,
right?
But and and you have to have that
understanding be correct for this to
work. Because if you actually bring the
Christian position to the table, all of
your arguments fail.
All of their arguments fail because
they're a straw man. You're not actually
you're not actually steel manning and
representing what Christians actually
believe.
Yeah. Um Yeah. And so I couldn't have
said it any better. So, uh kudos to
Miles, man. Uh that's why you're the
host of the show. All right. Let's go to
the next uh slide here. Um let's see. Um
next, the seven pillars of the SCA
faith. So the spirit of prophecy, of
course, uh we know who this is, Ellen G.
White. Um so as we talk about that, um
how important is uh Ellen White to the
SDA church. Um I'll just kind of talk
about me for a quick second. When I was
on my way out, so like um I started
really uh questioning around 99 um or
so. And by the time I hit 2000 2001 um
I'm like bro I I don't know about Ellen
White because I saw I I found out about
the scapegoat problem uh in 99. And then
after that um I started to like and I
was reading uh Ellen White stuff before
that. Um I started reading um Adventist
Home. I was dating a girl I thought we
were going to you know get married. So I
started reading that and uh with her and
she you know we kind of went back and
forth a little bit on some of the stuff
that we were like maybe that sounds
right. eh, maybe that doesn't sound
quite right, but you know, we'll just go
with it, whatever. Um, and so as we as I
studied and as she studied and on her
own and stuff like that and we end up
not being together anymore, whatever the
case was, I still wanted to check out a
couple things. And as I started reading
some of this stuff, I was like, I don't
know if I buy into this cuz I already
was having problems with uh some of the
stuff as we saw in the uh councils on
diet and food foods and um some of the
other um more uh some other kinds of
doctrines and they're problematic. Um I
was reading the 20 back in the day it
was uh oh it was 27 fundamental
doctrines. I hope y'all can still hear
me. Um
there you go.
Hey, bro. You muted yourself.
While he gets that figured out, he
accidentally muted himself. I think his
headphones are what came unplugged.
But no worries. That's what happens when
we're doing things live. There's always
some sort of technical issues that want
to arise. Looks like his mic actually
came unplugged because I can't even
unmute it from my end. While he's
getting that figured out, folks, you can
look up go to Google and type in the
statement of confidence in the writings
of Ellen G. White and it will pop up for
you. I could actually do that for us
right now to get the uh screen share
going here.
So, when you bring this up, I'm going to
zoom out some here. When you bring this
up, you're going to notice that
the SD church is very forthright in this
belief.
Statement of confidence in the writings
of LG White. Official statements July 7,
2015.
They regularly
regularly
update this.
Okay?
Go to Google. Every GC session, they
vote on this, which is why you'll see
some of the language they use here in a
second. As delegates to the 2015 General
Conference session in San Antonio,
Texas, we express our deep gratitude to
God for the continuing presence of the
various spiritual gifts among his people
and particularly for the prophetic
guidance we have received through the
life and ministry of Ellen G. White.
Whoops, sorry.
On the centennial of her death, we
rejoice that her writings have been made
available around the globe in many
languages and in a variety of printed
and electronic formats.
We reaffirm our conviction that her
writings are divinely inspired, truly
Christc centered, and Bible-based.
Rather than replacing the Bible, they
uplift the normative character of
scripture and correct inaccurate
interpretations of it derived from
tradition, human reason, personal
experience, and modern culture.
We commit ourselves to study the
writings of LG White prayerfully and
with hearts willing to follow the
councils and instructions we find there.
So when they try to tell you, "Oh, no,
no, no, no, no. We don't elevate Ellen
White's writings to the be equal with
scripture,
right? You may not personally, but the
SDA church does. They can double talk
all they want and try and downplay it,
but she's part of these mutually
supportive clusters. So, when he talks
about here the
pillar of the spirit of prophecy, she's
part of the framework. She's part of
what's necessary. You have to have it
for the whole thing to stay up.
And that's because the great controversy
theme is essentially coming from her for
everything else to then be filtered
through. She's the conduit from God.
She's the stamp of approval. It says in
early writings,
she's the stamp of approval from God to
know that he is communicating with the
movement,
giving them the great controversy theme,
etc.
Brother, welcome back. Sorry about that.
Yeah,
I can now you're fine. You can share
your slides again. We can get all that
stuff set back up. But
All right. Yeah.
Yeah. Don't Don't let them fool you,
Christian, or or try and tell you that
um well, they're really just uh we we
don't elevate Ellen White's writings.
They're uh I don't even believe them.
You know, you'll get SDAs all across the
board that are like, "Well, I'm an
Adventist, but I reject Ellen White
being a prophet." Well, then your entire
system is going to collapse. You have to
have all of these pillars.
All of the pillars. So,
facts. Okay. Sorry about that. Um, yeah.
So, where was I? Oh, yeah. I was I was
sharing um the fact that uh I was
looking into uh Ellen White's writings
and some of the stuff just wasn't
sitting well with me. Um and I got to
the point where I said, you know what,
maybe I'll just be a a Sabbath keeper.
I'll just go to church, you know? Um, I
still feel like the church, and this
might sound familiar, guys. I still feel
like the 7th Day Adventist Church has
the most truth,
right? I feel like, uh, this is about
right. So, I'll just do that. Maybe I
just won't um, you know, buy into Ellen
White so much. Okay. And you can try
that if you want to. Feel free. Um, I
think that you're going to, uh, run it
to the point where, um, you don't really
get what SDAism without Ellen White.
There is no Seventh Day Adventism
without Ellen White, you know, and shout
out to Elsa Thunder, Lauren, Pastor
Thunder. Um, he has said it like this.
Ellen White is to SDAism as uh Muhammad
is to Islam. Is that serious, right? Um,
and come to find out years and years and
years later, like I've been out 20 years
now and and counting, right? Um, that
yes, this is 100% factual, right? You
cannot get uh out of uh 7th Day
Adventism without Ellen White. It just
doesn't happen. Okay, so let's go to the
next uh slide, guys. Um catchphrases uh
for Ellen White's writing. Spirit of
prophecy, the testimonies, and sometimes
um the spirit of prophecy is used to uh
speak about specific books uh that she
wrote in the first five volumes, I
believe, uh there or so of her writing.
So, um just be careful. The context of
course dictates what um what it means,
you know. So, just be wise in when
you're speaking to 7day Adventist to ask
uh what they mean when they're saying
certain phrases. Okay. Um I like this
slide here. This is uh Miles is doing uh
Mount St. Ellen's book. That's Mount St.
Ellens or Mount St. Helens uh in uh uh
Northwest Pacific Northwest, but Mount
St. Ellens uh taller than a human being
here. All of the additions to scripture.
Uh my my my uh
unbelievable how much he's written here
um and borrowed in that uh that mess
there. So let's see. The Holy Ghost is
the author of the scriptures and of the
spirit of prophecy.
Hold up. Hold up. Hold up. Hold up.
Folks, it's right there.
Yeah.
Adventists
when they try and use their favorite
quote. Folks, we know the quote. We know
it. We and you're abusing that quote
too. She never called herself a prophet.
Then why is she codified in the
fundamental beliefs as being a prophet
who speaks with prophetic authority and
is the identifying mark of the remnant
church?
Hello. So you don't think you're the
remnant then? Because if you're
downplaying her, you then have to
downplay being the remnant. Again,
another thing that's part of this whole
connected web of things.
And then if the remnant falls, all their
interpretation of revelation collapses.
This is what I'm saying about their
whole system has to be true for it to
work. Whereas in Christianity, there are
things that I'm happy to say I'm wrong
on,
but I don't know what they are or I
wouldn't believe them,
right?
But my whole system doesn't collapse
because I'm wrong about what a figure in
Revelation, which is apocalyptic
literature, I I might be wrong about a
figure there.
My whole system is not built on that.
I could be wrong on that. And yet their
structure and foundation still stands.
It's like a picture falling off the
wall.
Not the foundation getting a massive
crack in it,
which is what theirs is. So the whole
structure now just completely falls in
on itself. But folks, it is right there.
It's right there. If the Holy Spirit
authored her writings and the Bible,
there's not this like, well, it's two
tiers of like, well, it's it's the Holy
Spirit speaking here, but like over here
it's more authoritative,
right? No, it's all the Holy Spirit.
It's all the Holy Spirit.
Yeah. And and and um well, we talk about
that, you know, in the scriptures. It's
like, you know, these writings of Paul
and of Peter and of John and of you
know, others uh in scriptures, Jude and
so forth, you know, these James and
whoever else, Moses and all that, you
know, they were they're canonized
because the spirit wrote them, right? So
if the spirit is the author of the
scriptures and the spirit of prophecy
like her writings, why not canonize
them?
Well, and that's the thing is they'll
tell you, "No, no, no, she's not a
canonical prophet." Then why does she
function as one?
There you go.
A local prophet. Their authority ended
when they died.
They were a local prophet for that time
and that period etc. Unless God then
canonized them like Isaiah
or Ezekiel or Daniel,
but they they are stuck. They're in an
infinite catch22 in like every every
category. They want to say, "Oh, well,
no, no, no. She was just a local
prophet. She's not an addition to
scripture. Then why does she function as
a canonical prophet?"
There you go.
Because she does. She's speaking from
the grave. And they went through a whole
thing in 1916 after she died where they
had to figure out, well, what are we
going to do? For example, if we find
errors now that she's dead because she
was making errors.
And Willie White came out and is on
record saying in selected messages.
Oh well, Mrs. White was directed by the
Lord, her son Willie White. Mrs. White
was directed by the Lord when to make
corrections, when to add things, when to
take stuff away.
Right?
Well, but now that she's dead, how do we
do that? because if people find errors,
uh oh, we're gonna have problems. So,
they had to go through a whole thing of
how do we keep Mrs. White speaking from
the grave. Well, she's supposed to be a
local prophet, but she functions like a
canonical prophet, but we only believe
the Bible.
Make it make sense,
right? Um and you know, the the funny
thing is like, you know, you can you can
say that um people made mistakes, right?
Um, but when you start to talk about
error in doctrine, show me any error in
doctrine that's made from the
canatonical prophets. Any
what what error in in theological um uh
uh in the theological framework did they
make?
Not even the apostles had the audacity
to say every word that I've written
inspired,
right?
She did. And Adventists want to downplay
that sort of stuff, too. and they'll
say, "Oh, well, no, it's it's Christ
Object Lessons and the Conflict of the
Ages series." Not true. They like to try
and fault this platform when I'm citing
for manuscript releases, uh, just across
the gamut of writings,
Sons and Daughters.
I didn't go and quote mine all this
stuff either. I read I've read these
books,
and yet they want to fault me for
saying, "Well, you don't even understand
how she works, bro.
You're you you're using stuff outside
the Conflict of the Ages series." Okay,
let's just use the Conflict of the Ages
series. Okay, let's just use Desire of
Ages,
right? Okay. plenty of nonsense.
I can show you all of the problems from
just Desire of Ages. I select I select
from across the gamut because I like
people to see a variety of the way
things are worded sometimes a certain
way because she says the same thing but
words it differently. Um that sort of
thing. Yet you get Ted Wilson, Steven
Boore, all these bigname hot shot SDAs.
They're quoting from across the gamut.
They're quoting early writings,
evangelism, the testimonies,
confrontation, all the compilation
books, councils on diet and foods. Oh,
but every time they do it, it's just,
"Oh, yeah, of course." And it's just
obvious. Like when you were on that time
with Dr. O,
remember it was just obvious the spirit
of prophecy because these Catholics,
they know what she's saying. Look,
they're just quoting Ellen Sister White.
It's just obvious what she's saying
because it's just at face value. Oh, but
if you're saying something critical, no,
no, no, no, no. You need a master,
Miles.
You need a master's degree to be able to
read this third grade educated woman.
So, I I'm not buying that. And this
woman made a claim that not even the
apostles made.
And nor did they write as much as this
woman did to claim such an authority.
Let's go to the next one, guys. Um, the
Lord has given me much light and I want
the people to have. Uh, for there is
instruction that the Lord has given me
for his people. It is like that they
should have line upon line, precept upon
precept, and here a little and there a
little. There is now to come before the
people because it has been I'm sorry, it
has been given to correct specious
errors and to specify what is truth. The
Lord has revealed many things pointing
out to the truth. Uh thus saying this is
the way walk ye in it. The selected
messages poke 3 page 32. All right. Um
and so again uh who gets the light?
Ellen gets the light. The Lord has given
me much light. And again, this uh this
uh quote or misquote, if you will, of
Isaiah 28 is terrible. First and
foremost, if you want to talk about
context, um if you ever talk about
context, and you're going to get this
from me, and I'm telling this in love,
if I ever, and I mean ever, hear anybody
in my circle talk about context, and
then you want to use line upon line,
precept upon precept, here a little,
there a little, I might I might smack
you. All right. So, I'm definitely gonna
talk about you your face.
It's what the black Hebrew Israelites
use that verse to say the same thing the
SDAs do
to try and say it is teaching to
hopscotch all over the Bible and string
together stuff that has literally
nothing to do sometimes with one
another.
But they then use word association
fallacy to just jump all over the place
is crazy. Folks, we have an article on
this on our page. I've actually had a
SDA recently who he's just it's a slam
dunk. He he thinks he has a slam dunk.
He's like, "You're you're not even
getting the context of Isaiah 28." No,
no. I understand the the context of
Isaiah 28, buddy. The issue is what's in
focus is the phrase that's being pulled
from which is this line upon line,
precept upon precept. Here a little,
there a little.
And it's these arrogant leaders who
think that they're above correction or
ab or above being taught. And they're
mocking God's prophet. And it's the
start of a pronouncement of woes that go
all the way to like chapter 33 or
something like that.
And Isaiah brings them a message warning
them. They mock him. And they're the
first ones that say. And they say it
because they're teachers. We're told
that they're teachers of Israel. So
they're arrogant, prideful teachers who
act as though they are above correction.
And God's prophet comes to correct them.
And they say, "Are you gonna teach us
like little babies who have just been
weaned from the mother's breast, line
upon line, precept upon precept?" Yeah.
Exactly. Yeah. They're they're mocking
him. And Isaiah, God speaking through
Isaiah, tells them, "Yeah, to you it
will be line upon line, precept upon
precept, and it's going to knock you
back down." Basically, I'm going to
humble you essentially.
Right?
It has nothing to do with teaching
hermeneutics. And that prophecy is
talking about the cornerstone of Christ
and then Christ quotes it in the the
gospels. But um it has nothing to do
with hermeneutics,
right?
Or how to study the Bible. You're using
the words of drunkards,
right?
Well, well, people that are more than
likely drunk on some sort of power, but
nevertheless,
no, no, it is it's drunkenness because
if I may, if I may just jump in real
quick.
Oh, yeah. Because he talks about the
puke being everywhere.
Exactly. Right. And um even worse than
this guys, um if you get into the
ancient near context and you start to
look at the um the uh goddess worship in
Egypt, Mut, part of their worship was
for uh being inebriated, like getting
skunk drunk, passing out, throwing up
all over the place, and getting
revelations from this god mut goddess
Mut. Okay? So if you're using that sort
of thing and trying to do that with
Yahweh, you know, King of Kings, Lord of
Lords, then you're in big trouble, okay?
And that these what these uh men are
doing here. Okay? So you have not only
just the immediate context of the um
like using this line um or this phrase
here as if it's uh instructions for
Bible study. It's not. Right? Then you
have to go a little bit further and you
see how there these these bad um um
preachers and pastors and if you want to
call them that or priests are doing the
wrong thing. There's that problem and
God is rebuking them. There's that
problem. And then on top of that uh you
know utilizing um things from the world
synretatism if you will you know um
things that are used to worship false
gods you know and and trying to
incorporate that into Yahweh worship.
It's a problem. Okay. So there are
multiple layers on this. And then you
have the audacity to say this is how
we're going to study Ellen White on top
of that. You're nuts.
Yeah, it's a pro.
So,
it has nothing to do with hermeneutics.
Thank you very much. All right. Um,
let's see. Quote, "Those who resist the
messages of God through his humble
servant, that's me, uh, think they are
at variance with Sister White because
her ideas are not in harmony with
theirs. But this variance is not with
Sister White. It is with the Lord who
has given her her work to do. Uh
reviewing Herald, uh August 26th, 1890.
Like
you got beef with Ellen White. You
actually have beef with God.
Who says this?
This is what I'm saying. Adventists, she
makes these crazy claims.
They love to latch on to like the
flowery claims, you know, the stuff that
is just like, "Oh, but look at this
quote over here." Yeah, look at this one
over here. Let's talk about these. We
never talk about these, which there's
far more of these than the her borrowing
from some orthodox, you know, person,
but not actually understanding what the
person's saying. There's far more of
these. Who makes a claim like this?
Mhm.
Your beef ain't with me. It's with God.
I mean, dude, you that's like, do you
have any fear of God before your eyes?
Do you understand who you claim to be
speaking on behalf of?
I bring this up all the time. You want
to claim to be the commandmentkeeping
church, yet you guys bind the conscience
of millions of people, whether they
accept it or not, to accept that a woman
from the 19th century who bore the name
of God falsely over and over and over
again, violating the third commandment.
You want to bind people's conscience to
that and tie salvation to understanding
this and believing all of this because
that's essentially what it is. Salvation
is believing the system. You have to
have her to have the great controversy
theme and all that other stuff.
You want to tell me that a woman who
violated the third commandment over and
over and over again, that's the
commandment keeping church. Okay.
Unbelievable, man. Um yeah. So, we're
going to go to the next uh quote here.
Um but again, why why are we even uh
incorporating this, right? Um because
again if Ellen White um if she she's she
cannot be questioned and her writings
cannot be questioned and she is
promoting all the rest of this stuff
here which is going to be you'll see at
the the big the biggie here u the main
pillar um then you have to wonder like
what is really going on right Ellen
White cannot be questioned it is it it
is a fundamental belief to believe in
Ellen White and her writings and her
mission right well not just that. But
like we were saying, she's a pillar.
Yeah.
What do the pillars do?
Right. If you if you take away Ellen
White's writings, what do you have left
in Ellen in in Seventh Day Adventism?
Yeah. You can't have the great
controversy theme without her.
And it's the the answer to everything.
It's the mind of God.
Or it's the connection point to to be
able to have that.
All right. Yeah. And this is uh and
great perfect segue, Miles. Um this is
GI Butler. Okay. Um and I was looking at
some stuff with this guy. He uh he was
um fairly young. All right. Um and he
was barely uh I think he was u maybe
ordained for uh maybe 10 years uh prior
to becoming uh elevated as GC president.
We we can talk about that later some
other time. But it's a lot of nepotism
going on here. Anyway, um he says this,
"Our position on the testimonies is like
the keystone to the arch. Take that out.
And there is no logical stopping place
till all the special truths of the
message are gone. Our enemies and the
master they serve realize this. Watch
this. But some of our people are so
blind that they do not Hello.
Okay. Reviewing Herald supplement August
14th 1883. I got the PDF if you want it.
Okay. This is the thing here guys that
you need to recognize. Even if you think
like year 2000, year 2001 uh CMBB was
right where I thought I could live in an
SDA bubble without Ellen White. There's
no stopping place if you take her out,
right? There's no stopping place. So all
the special truths of the message are
gone. And some of the people are so
blind that they don't realize it. I did
not realize it. I thought I thought she
was optional.
I thought, you know what? I don't have
to uh buy into everything she says.
She's just a good person. Sure, why not?
Whatever the case is, I'll just live my
life and keep Sabbath and do all the
things that I know to be right. But what
I didn't realize was if she's involved,
she's involved in everything.
Okay. 100%. I remember when I first read
this, I was like, "Wow." Like I love
when they just like show their hand
and just say it as it is. Thank you.
Thank you. Because part of the mission
of this platform, folks,
is or or one of the things that drove me
to do this, which was a number of
things. And one of the goals here is I
want Adventists to be honest.
Yeah.
Forth. This is forthright. It's not
beating around the bush. This is from a
different era.
This is a different era than the modern
day. Oh, no, no, no. We're a diverse,
you know, the sort of Pacific Northwest
style SDA. Um, that sort of thing. No,
this is honest. This is showing your
hand. This guy would have told me, "No,
you're lost. If you don't come join
this, you know, end times last day
remnant church after hearing this
message, you're going to be lost." More
SDAs need to have that level of tenacity
and that level of boldness and honesty
because if you truly believe what you
believe, you should be honest about
that. We're willing to be honest on this
platform. We get faulted a lot.
Oh, you're mean. Oh, you're the No,
we're honest. We may have tough love and
we may deliver it a certain way because
God's given people different
personalities. Maybe I am a son of
thunder. Yeah, I'm a little bit more
fiery than some people, but at the end
of the day, no, I care enough to say
something and I'm willing to take the
arrows that get shot my way because they
do show up. Folks, you should see our
email. You should see our email. I'm
serious.
Hate.
It's not just me saying It's not just me
saying it. We're going to be looking at
some of that next week, which is our
oneyear anniversary great disappointment
Belooza celebration.
But I get all sorts of arrows from these
people. Not even them. I get people that
are mad who have never been SDA who are
mad that I'm saying stuff about SDA,
right?
You I mean, you have to have a thick
skin for this, folks. But I'm willing to
do that not to get clicks on the
internet,
not because we're we're trying to gas up
our RG6 out back on the runway because
we're in this for the money, right?
Of course. Right.
No, it's because we care enough to say
the truth. And I wish more SDAs would be
like this guy because then we could
actually make some progress. But I think
the problem is is that they're afraid to
be able to have to defend some of those
things if you do end up going that
route.
Right. Well, I mean to be honest, right,
I mean, let's be let's be let's be
perfectly honest. Uh Miles, if if every
SDA said, you know what, um take Ellen
White out and then we don't have a
reason to be around anymore, right? um
that would be like, you know, one of the
signs of a cult, like a really
charismatic leader that you can't live
without, that you can't interpret the
scriptures without, right? You know, um
and so some people would be like, well,
no, we we definitely uh don't want to
look like a cult, right? So, we would
never say or admit that uh Ellen White
is the keystone in the arch. Right.
Right.
We would never we would never do that.
What happens if you take the keystone
out of the arch? the arch collapses,
guys. It's it's physics, right? You
cannot have an arch function without a
keystone. It doesn't work that way. All
right.
And do you think the SDA church has
changed that? Like, you know, I I I just
I always whenever I read this stuff, I
always know the responses. That was back
then, bro. It's changed. It's changed.
Yeah. You think the SDA church would
repudiate that statement?
Yeah.
I have yet to see them ever. Ever. And
I'm not saying it's not out there. I'm
just saying I've looked at a lot of SDA
source materials, folks. Like a lot. And
I don't know people who are scouring
their archives just reading,
right?
And like getting familiar with these
sorts of things. I have yet to find a
single statement anywhere of them
repudiating anything a pioneer said.
It didn't matter how damnably heretical
it is. No atonement was made at the
cross. Let this fact be fixed forever in
your mind.
The old anti Yeah. the old
anti-Christian heretical trinitarian
creed. I I mean all these statements I
have yet to see them repudiate any of
them. So if if you think this is the
first one, show me the source that says
that. But otherwise, they still stand by
this.
We read the statement of confidence in
her writings. You can look at her own
writings. You can look at quotes like
this. I mean, this has been the position
and will be the position because it is a
system.
That's right. That's right. Um, and it
and it can't it relies solely on Ellen
White. Now, did you have the um Were you
going to play that later, the Jim Nick
interview, or do you do you are you were
you worried about that at all anymore or
No.
Um, we'll probably save that for another
time.
Okay. Sure. No problem. All right. So,
yeah. So, um, what I was talking about,
guys, um, for those that don't know, uh,
Jim Nicks was the, uh, I think it's the
director of the Elite Estate, if I'm not
mistaken. Um,
yeah. And so he had this uh this well
he's just kind of talking um and he
talks about like how the great
controversy um vision came about, right?
Um and he's very forthcoming about it,
you know? He just says it was a vision,
right? Um and you'll have SDA apologists
that will argue us down and tell us,
"Oh, no, no, no, that came from Bible
study." No, it didn't. Right? Uh and we
we get to the next uh pillar when we
start talking about the and it's funny
on this picture it's the smallest pillar
but it's really the biggest one uh 1844
uh investigative judgment right um that
didn't come from Bible study either that
came from a vision and we'll look at
that you know um I actually meant to put
that I should have put that in the
slides I was worried about it being too
long but um I'll read a quote here uh
from kingdom the kingdom of the cults
and slash um uh prophetic faith of our
fathers volume 4 uh You can get those
PDFs uh any place at this point um free
as well. Uh so check them out. But um
let's uh go ahead and and proceed uh
family. Um yeah, 1844 investigative
judgment. Okay, so again uh the previous
uh pillars. Okay, a prepared people. If
you're not prepared, you can't see the
Lord in peace, right? Um number two was
what was it? I forgot already. Um it was
the um uh I can't remember. Anyway,
Ellen White was
last message.
Uh that was the first one. Yeah,
prepared people. Oh, the state of the
dead. That's right. Um, the state of the
dead was the next one. Um, then Ellen
White. If any of those three falter,
there's no point, right? But then, of
course, this is the key of the key of
the key of the key, the sanctuary
doctrine/1844ig
J. All right. So, um, for those of you
who know, um, oops, for those of you who
know, um, the SDA church, and it's
coming up in a couple days here. Happy
Great Disappointment. Early great
disappointment, guys. uh for uh October
22nd 1844. Um that was the beginning of
the
end be I don't know what it's called but
that was the thing right that made uh
brought all these people together
millerism's uh culmination date of the
last possible day that Christ would
return uh 1844 October 22nd and of
course that did not happen um and the
folks that remained um was about 150 of
them if I'm uh uh correct Adventists at
that point um which I know the church
wasn't incorporated yet blah blah blah
we know Um, but you know, it's one of
those things that we have to recognize
that there was a serious uh paradigm
shift that happened. Um, and I think a
stealing s ling of the mind uh against
any kind of correction after that and
they just went with it. You know, that's
just my personal opinion. You can argue
um about that if you want to, but when
we look at the text and um and the uh
the writings, we look at the testimonies
of the people that were there at the
time. Um we look at the doctrines that
came forth from that time and you know
that it's the ultimate double down um of
error. Okay. Um let's see. Uh Ellen
White says great controversy page 409.
Uh the spir the scripture, pardon me,
which was above all others, had been
both the foundation and central pillar
of the advent faith was the declaration
unto 2,300
days, then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed. Daniel 8:14.
She says that it's the central pillar.
If you want to argue that 1844, the
sanctuary message and whatever is not
the central pillar, you you have to
argue with Ellen White. Okay? I'm not
saying this. She's saying this. So argue
it with her. Okay. Um this is what um
excuse. These had been familiar words to
all believers in the Lord's soon coming.
By the lips of thousands was this
prophecy repeated as the watchword of
their faith. Unto 2,000 300 days. Then
sanctuary shall be cleansed. Not for God
so loved the world that he became his
only begotten son. Not you know what I
received um I pass unto you. you know,
yeah, Christ was uh uh uh crucified and
rose again on the third day. None of
that was the by word of their faith or
the watch word. This nonsense was all
felt that upon the events therein uh
foretold depended their brightest
expectations and most cherished hopes.
These prophetic days had been shown to
terminate in the autumn of 1844.
Um, fun fact, it actually uh was
supposed to terminate uh in the spring
of 1843
or somewhere in the spring of 1844,
someplace in between there. Uh,
until Samuel Snow, right,
crackpot, who thought he was the return
of Elisha the prophet before the second
coming, did some crazy wonky math and it
it now landed on 18 o specifically
October 22nd,
the 184, right? The seventh. nonsense,
right? So, um but yeah, this is this is
it's crazy, man. It really it's crazym,
right? Um here's here's another quote.
Uh great controversy. You can see the
reference there, page 409. Uh in common
with the rest of the Christian world,
Adventists then held that the earth or
some portion of it was the sanctuary.
They understood that the cleansing of
the sanctuary was the purification of
the earth by the fires of the last great
day. And this would take place at the
second advent. Hence the conclusion that
Christ would return to the earth in
1844, you know. Um so again, this is the
whole point uh of everything else. So
the sanctuary doctrine. Um okay, jump
in. Yep.
If you don't mind.
Yeah.
Um go back to that quote.
Sure.
This is the other thing that's common,
folks, that you have to pay attention to
that happens constantly in their
movement.
Notice what she says at the very first
sentence. in common with the rest of the
Christian world.
No, the rest of the Christian world did
not agree that the earth or some portion
of it was the sanctuary to be cleansed
in octo in Daniel 8:14.
But see, she just says stuff like this
and then SDAs parrot this stuff and I
hear them say and I always call them on
it. I'm like, well, hold up, hold up,
hold up, hold up.
Who who is all? Because there's things
that they'll that they that they teach
or will say that, "Oh, all people at the
time believed this." Like they love to
do this with the uh the shouting
Methodist nonsense. They love to say,
"Oh, well, all Protestants were or
evangelicals at that time were like
that. That's just how it was back then
to try and downplay the fact that Ellen
White grew up in these sort of fanatical
fringe offshoot movements." Um, and no,
that's not the case. The majority of
Christians were not like that back then.
So she does that same thing here. Well,
the majority of the Christians believed
this. This wasn't some, you know, unique
thing at that time. Yes, it was. It was
unique to the people at that time when
imminency was not the popular belief of
the day. So what Miller was preaching
was anomalous at the time. So hearing
something like that became very
captivating to a number of people. But
see, she just assumes it's the people
that were believing this that was the
Christian world at the time. Those who
were believing this, then it really
whittleled down to the little flock and
then turned into the 7th day Adventist
movement. And this is again, I mentioned
this this this past week that they've
really borrowed from three different
groups of people throughout history to
try and add relevance or some sort of
Christian street cred to the movement.
And that's Presbyterianism, Methodism,
but then universalist restorationism.
They don't like to formally identify
with the restorationist movement even
though they are a restorationist group
because you had James and Uriah Smith,
these other pioneers coming out of the
Christian Connection which was a
Unitarian Restorationist group, but then
you had people like Bates that came out
of Presbyterianism. And then you've got
Ellen coming out of Methodism, the
fringe shouting, you know, crazy wacky
Methodists. Um, and that's what this
system is essentially built off of. It's
an amalgamation of the things that they
like from all these different groups
made into one singular system. And so
this idea that oh the rest of the
Christian world, no folks, the rest of
the Christian world did not agree that
Daniel 8:14 is talking about if
anything, if anything, the majority of
Christians at the Christian world at the
time and still to this day disagrees
that that has anything to do with the
earth being the sanctuary. Not to be
confused with the fact that Christians
believed that the temple on the earth,
not some heavenly sanctuary, but the
earthly sanctuary is in focus. But
that's not what Miller was saying.
Miller was saying the whole earth was
the sanctuary that was going to be
burned by fire.
So to try and say, oh well, all
Christians at that time because they
believed that the earthly temple was
what was in view because they believed
it was Antioch's epiphies long before
1844. But that's not the equivalent of
what Miller was saying. And no, the rest
of the Christian world did not believe
that.
Yeah. Um, so a couple things I wanted to
address real quick. Um, there was
doctrines exposed. Yeah. This statement
is according to the 2,300 year prophecy.
Exact date is debatable. Debatable. Um,
no, not really. Um, because if you were
to uh say that um then you have to kind
of throw away um the the way they
calculated the dates. Okay. Uh so they
actually had to use um some of the older
Jewish calendars. Funny enough, there
are lunar calendars. We're not going to
talk about that tonight, but whatever.
Like lunar calendars uh there. And they
use some of those things and they try to
find the right feast day uh the
appropriate feast day to um to uh uh
address the the actual date that they
came up with, which was October 22nd,
1844. Now, um if you do any additional
research, you'll find out that it didn't
quite match up exactly. Um but that was
the last year because of the seventh
month prophecy and so forth like that um
that Samuel Snow uh added into it. Okay.
So it's a it's a whole convoluted mess.
Um and yes uh yes government calendar
and lun calendar are different. Perfect.
Yes. Uh so that's right. And then also
Adam and Eve says uh world is not just
American. Exactly right. However, um the
esquetology um the SDA esquetology is
really um and especially how uh
revelation 13 is uh is interpreted. It
has to be America according to their um
esque escatological
framework or else the whole thing
collapses. Right. Um I did a show with
uh the BK apologist who was just on here
uh in the chat earlier, Mr. Phil Fox who
was in here earlier. Shout out to you,
brother. Um I did we did a ch a show
together um showing uh that the land was
not empty. Okay. Uh this was done on Mr.
on BK apologist channel. The land was
not empty. And we showed um looking at
the scriptures um and how the SDAs have
interpreted scriptures historically what
was happening in this country um and
seeing that the world the the land
actually was not empty. And so what
Ellen White says happens in the Greek
controversy, how this uh this land, this
beast power grows up in a previously
unoccupied land. That's a it's patently
false. All right. So just crushed.
It's just a fact. Like you know,
it's just the facts.
Yeah. So you you can't you can't have
your cake and eat it too. The fact that
they're using um many waters as a sign
of people, which is true in Revelation,
I think it's chapter 17, I think. Uh
that explains that 161 17 somewhere in
there. Um, and then uh dry land equals
uh an uninhabited place is patently
false. They're making an argument from
silence. If you want more information,
go check that video out. Okay.
And if this collapses, if that
collapses,
yeah,
their whole system collapses because
it's built on esquetology.
Mhm.
It's a crack in the foundation.
This is what I'm saying. You have to
have every detail right on all of these.
The thing is is see folks it's just well
it's just the Bible to them because
whether they understand or not the
average SDA they are taking a system
that says we have it all figured out.
God has told us this therefore it's
correct. So therefore it has to be what
it is regardless of any sort of holes
that are poked in it or or stuff that's
erroneous like this because the great
controversy theme says that
and it's necessary for this system. So
that's just what it is. But that's not
just believing the Bible. That's not
what just believing the Bible means.
That's not how that works. So um just a
a pointer there on how the great
controversy theme really functions even
at that level.
Yeah. All right. Excellent. Okay. So
let's move on to the next uh thing here,
guys. Um where we at? Oh, yeah. So the
Adventist Review um you can see this uh
article here uh September 20th I'm sorry
September 3rd 2020 sanctuary doctrine um
and it's going to talk about the
importance of the sanctuary doctrine
again this is the pillar the pillar um
the pillar of pillars if you will um it
says quote Richard Davidson here says
the doctrine of the sanctuary lies at
the foundation of 7th day Adventist
theology how much more clear can you get
Okay. And mission and con constitutes
the most distinctive contribution of
Adventism to Christian thought. While
other Adventist quote unquote
distinctives, 7th day, Sabbath, Day of
the Dead, tithing, etc. are taught by
various Christian denominations, the 7th
Day Adventist Church is the only major
faith group teaching the good news of
the three angels message that in these
last days of earth's history, the hour
of his judgment is come. Revelation 14
uh 6-7. Now, we're going to continue
that quote here a second, but I just
thought it was funny. I thought it was
kind of comical that uh Adventist
distinctives, 7th Day Sabbath, Day of
the Dead tithing are taught by various
Christian denominations. Okay? Something
that's distinct, right? It means that
it's going to be uh more something that
you do that other people don't do. Okay?
Or something that you look like that
other people don't look like. So, your
your your voice is distinct. Um, your
sense of humor is distinct. Your looks
are distinct. That makes you different.
So, how in the world are distinctives
being taught by other people? That I
just thought that was comical uh and
ironic. So, just humor me here. Um,
moving on. He continues to say, um, for
Adventist pioneers, the subject of the
sanctuary was the key. Listen y'all,
which unlocked the mystery of the
disappointment of 1844.
It opened to view a complete system of
truth connected and harmonious showing
that God's hand had directed the great
Advent movement and revealing present
duty as it um brought to light the
position and work of his people. End
quote. The This is probably the most
egregious thing that I've seen. The
subject of the sanctuary was the key
which unlocked the mystery of the
disappointment of 1844. Not the fact
that you just made it up and something
just didn't happen that you thought
happened. Right? That would be a way
easier uh admission right there. Right?
But no, you have to have this convoluted
mess um and call it sanctuary doctrine
uh in order to make it make sense.
Right? And even still, it doesn't make
sense. All right? So, Miles, feel free
to chime in. The evidence of that,
folks, is in the fact that the 19th
century version of this doctrine was is
not the same as the 20th century. The
the 21st century is not the same as the
20th century. Dez Ford
documents this down in his book
because it came out in the 20th century
and how he he does a side by side and
it's like pages and pages of points that
shifted from the 19th to the 20th.
Well, then you can compare because again
it came out in the 20th. You can then
compare that column with those same
positions and look them up today and see
what the 21st century iteration is. that
will be something that's added to the
website at some point. Um because it's
just
such a the tool is like absolutely
excellent. It's like a great reference
guide essentially to be able to look at
the evolution of this because then he
has the quotes showing where to go to
see where the authoritative sources were
at the time. Um but nevertheless,
yeah, it's not even the same teaching
today that it was two centuries ago. Yet
the subject of the sanctuary is the key
which unlocked the mystery of the dis
disappointment in 1844.
So how does the key keep changing?
Again, I keep going back to the same
question, folks. I thought the great
controversy theme was supposed to solve
all of this division and confusion.
Why do you have to have present truth if
you have the theory of everything?
Yeah, that's a good question, right?
Yet you have to have present truth for
the whole thing to work. All right. You
know, it's funny this talking about the
keys keep changing. You know, the door
is still locked. Like
Yeah. And it's locked and unlocked like
15 times. Just in the just in the
seven-year period, folks. Wow.
Really? A 10-year period,
but basically up to 1951.
Yeah. Dude, you have the door of
salvation, the door of mercy closing and
then opening and then closing again and
then squeaking open for a couple people
and then some of their kids because
they're kids at that point got to the
age of accountability and so they're
like, "Oh, well, there still has to be
somewhat of an opportunity." So, they
let the kids squeak through.
Then that door completely shut and
another door opened.
That was the evolution from a guy
getting a vision in a field, not Bible
study.
Mhm. a guy getting a vision in a field
and it getting published in the Day Star
being the saving grace for the movement
leading to Ellen White supposedly
getting a vision that confirms what
Croer saw or rather or Hyram Edson saw
and what Croer penned in the Day Star
where she in the Day Star says that what
he penned is correct.
Mhm. And then we looked at the second
vision, you and I, uh, on a different
stream where I went through that point
by point showing the the whole chain of
the story and how it evolved over time
and all this stuff leading to Joseph
Bates systematizing the teaching
essentially in um that 50s 19 or 1850s
period. So that's supposed to be the
key. You've got the theory of everything
in the great controversy theme. this
thing is the key to the mystery of 1844
and yet it's continued to evolve even
past that to oh well atonement did take
place at the cross like Ted was trying
to say in the annual council well yo
your pioneers didn't agree with that
so all of that to say um
it's just
talk about cope
right um I'm going to take a moment
remember we talked about u me reading um
the excerpt from prophetic face of our
fathers, right? Um, so I'm going to do
that now, guys. Um, so again, this is,
uh, volume four of Prophetic Faith of
Our Fathers, page 881. Um, this is going
to get quoted, um, in the Kingdom of the
Cults book. Um, I did this earlier, so
I'm reading off of my my little uh,
tablet here. So, that's why you're not
seeing it on your screen, guys. Um, but
I'm going to go ahead and read it. Um,
so you can see uh, this is a quote here.
It says, "As they walked through the
cornfield in deep silence and
meditation, Hyram Edson, this is the day
after uh the great disappointment, by
the way." Okay. Um Hyram Edson stopped,
became more deeply immersed in
meditation, and then with upturned face
indicative of a heartfelt prayer for
spiritual light, he suddenly received a
great spiritual revelation in the words
of SDA historian Leroy Froom. Okay, this
is quoted in Prophetic Faith of Our
Fathers Volume 4, page 881. It says,
quote, "Suddenly there burst upon his
mind the thought that there were two
phases of Christ's ministry in the
heaven of heavens. Just as in the
earthly sanctuary of old, in his own
words, an overwhelming conviction came
over him that instead of our high priest
coming out of the most holy uh of the
heavenly sanctuary to come to this earth
on the 10th day of the seventh month at
the end of the 2300 days. He for the
first time entered on that day the
second apartment of that sanctuary and
that he had a work to perform in the
most holy before coming to this earth.
Remember this is what he said. This
burst upon his mind the thought that
there are two phases of Christ's
ministry. I'm going to continue to quote
in that instant. According to 7th day
Adventist history, Hyram Advent uh Edson
found the reason found the reason why
the Millerites had been disappointed.
This does not sound like Bible study,
does it guys?
They had expected Christ to come to
earth to cleanse the sanctuary, but the
sanctuary was not the earth. It was
located in heaven. Instead of coming to
earth, therefore, Christ had passed from
one apartment of the sanctuary into the
other apartment to perform a closing
work now known as the investigative
judgment. That's from kingdom of the
cults. Let's go back to prophetic faith
of our fathers fathers volume 4. Okay.
Quote here, Edson and Croer, that's OL
Croer, then sought out of them uh sought
out their mutual friend, Dr. Franklin
Behan and the three of them agreed to
meet as a study group, listen to search
the Bible intensely along these lines
until all should be clear. They are
admitting that they are ising the text
in order to make sense of what happened
on October 8 22nd 1844 as opposed to
just recognizing they were wrong.
Next, the book of Hebrews, specifically
chapters 8 and 9, speaking of the
earthly sanctuary as a shadow of the
heavenly, a figure of the true, and with
its service as an example of the true
service, enforced the conviction of
their of the cornfield, and their
subsequent discussions as they went from
home to home. Right now, I had the the
the honor and privilege of doing um a
verse byvere study of the book of
Hebrews on my channel. This is Back to
Bible Basics uh season 2. Check it out.
Okay. And we go verse by verse. It took
us five months to go through the whole
book. All right. Um Miles, you talked
about your pastor is doing that right
now. Okay. Um so, and I'm sure he's a
better exit even than me. Uh so
thankfully uh you can uh check take
notes and uh get get all that stuff take
uh taken clearly. Okay. Quote continues.
Um the entire mosaic system of types and
ceremonies became the central area of
study together with their matching of
antiypical Christian realities and the
prophetic outlines of Daniel and the
revelation uh concerning the latter
times were also the subject of
painstaking review. This almost
continuous group study covering covering
not only weeks but months confirmed
their understanding of how and why
Christ had entered the most holy place
to cleanse it. That's prophetic faith of
our fathers volume 4 page 887.
This guys right here um is what you call
is Jesus. It is not exesus. We're not
looking to the text and seeing what the
text is saying to us and understanding
what the writers would have intended for
us to understand uh to be communicated
to us, the readers, okay, of these
words. No, no, no. They're bringing this
idea, well, something had happened,
right? How could we be wrong? We knew
Father Miller was correct, right? And
all of a sudden, here comes Hyram Medson
in the cornfield. They're literally
children of the corn. Happy Halloween,
everybody. um you know they're uh
they're they're walking in the cornfield
and this suddenly bursts on his mind.
It is a vision and then you have all
kinds of stuff here that they're ex
they're telling us that this comes from
scripture. No, no, it doesn't.
If I have an idea, oh I'll just conclude
here on my plane. Um, if I have an idea
and I take it to the text, for a lot of
people, they can make the text say
anything if you're text,
right? And they they try it all the
time, you know.
Go ahead, brother. Yeah.
I was just going to say that ultimately
where it's coming from, folks, we have
an article on this on our website, so
you can check this out for yourself
regarding the seven visionary doctrines
um of the SDA church. You can check this
out, like I said, on our website. All of
the stuff that's read folks is hyperl so
you can very easily click and it will
take you to so if you click this
headline the sanctuary and the
investigative judgment um it will take
you to right there the source you can
read it yourself which is what the
article essentially is talking about and
it's Joseph Bates was the first
individual to give the formal name
investigative judgment to the teaching
in 1855 we've thor thoroughly documented
this here as well as the shut door
aspect of it which was initially
foundational and Ellen said was blast
blasphemy against the Holy Spirit for
those that went against it.
Get that. Get that. Get that. Did you
hear that, folks?
It was blasphemy against the Holy Spirit
to go against the teaching. This was
born out of false prophecy
and then further false prophecy because
error always begets error. So, she went
further down the chain of saying, "Well,
God had his hand over a mistake. She
blamed God.
But then God told her the chart wasn't
supposed to change and it changed three
times
to better fit with the figures and the
numbers and Elisha uh or Samuel Snow the
re the return of Elisha the prophet etc.
In January 1846 as documented in the
Millerite dayar paper she supposedly had
the foundational vision for this which
was built upon later. The shutd door
theory was tied to the concept that
probation was closed and salvation was
no longer a possibility.
But once this was surrendered, something
had to be done to patch that hole.
This is what led to the sanctuary
vision. You can read it there. And the
subsequent open and shut door vision.
That's what I was saying about the door
opened and then it shut. And then all
right. Well, first it shut, then it
opened, then it shut, then it squeaked
open, then it was shut for good, but
then another door opened
where she claimed when one door closed,
another actually opened. This then
became the antidote for the previous
problems, which is where they are at
today.
And Dezfor documents some of that to
some degree down in his book because he
was writing it in the 20th century and
he writes about the shifts from the 19th
to the 20th and this is the sort of
stuff that was supporting that. But
nevertheless, all of that is ultimately
to say the reason that it is cemented in
is because it is one of the vision
doctrines. It was shown by God in vision
not just to Croer but then to Ellen
and that is what then cemented it into
the movement
boy. All right.
Let's see
next slide. Uh the sanctuary message is
not just one doctrine among many in 7th
day Adventist theology. In 1906, Ellen
White could write the correct
understanding of the ministration of the
heavenly sanctuary is the foundation of
our faith. End to quote evangelism page
221.
Adventist scholars both past and present
have shown how the sanctuary is the
center of all the major doctrinal truths
in the Bible. So again guys um Dr. Herb
Douglas is saying that these are a
mutually supportive cluster. Okay, they
cannot stand by themselves.
If you have no Ellen White, then you
don't have a confirmation of Hyer
Medson's vision.
Okay?
If you have no investigative judgment,
then there's no need to really hang your
hat on soul sleep. Some people agree
with that, some people don't. Okay,
fine. But it's not something that's
going to make or break um most people's
theology or their esquetology.
Seventh Day Adventists have to have uh
the state of the dead, quote unquote,
because if they don't, according to that
particular framework, the whole thing
collapses.
Okay? If we're trying to prepare
ourselves, right? Um and the uh the if
what meat eating will be cloud the mind
and not allow you to understand these
truths, well then you you'll be lost cuz
you can't understand it and you won't be
ready for when the Sunday laws come.
Okay? So the these are these are things
that all kind of hinge on each other.
Mutually supportive, guys. That's the
point for tonight. We're showing how
this is actually true. Um and what Dr.
Douglas said is correct.
and wrong. I think
yes, this is another area you mentioned,
state of the dead. Folks, this is
another area that is a part of the seven
visionary doctrines. It came from a guy
by the name of George Stores, which is
why whenever they try to say something
like um in my case, I'm a I'm in the
reformed tradition, so they like to say,
"You're just a a Calvinist. You follow
John Calvin," which is not what that
term means, by the way. Um, but I just
turn it back on them and I say, "You're
a stoist."
You follow George stores. Oh, right.
Because you agree with him on a single
thing. You shouldn't be called a George
storeite because you simply believe
something that this guy was also saying.
Gotcha. Okay, perfect. Point made.
But this is one of their seven pillar
doctrines. So, you can see that on there
as well. And that came before because
you well it gets into all the history of
that Rachel Oaks Preston and how this
guy George stores also influenced
Charles TA Russell of the Jehovah's
Witnesses which is why people oftentimes
associate soul sleep with SDAs and
Jehovah's Witnesses. Well, it goes back
to George Stores. So, you can check that
out on the website as well.
Excellent. Okay. Um at answering
adaptism.com, guys, check it out. All
right, let's go. The sanctuary doctrine
focuses upon Jesus in the sanctuary,
including one, his atoning work on the
cross, which functions as a sacrificial
altar of the heavenly sanctuary, Hebrews
13:10. And two, his heavenly
ministration of intercession for us,
Hebrews 7:25. And three, his work of
vindicating his people during the
pre-advent judgment. Okay. Um, again,
what are we talking about here? This is
going to we're going to see a little bit
more about that last point here uh as we
get to uh the final um uh uh pillar
there. Okay. Uh vindicating his people
during the pre-advent judgment. Again,
what is the whole point? Uh the great
controversy theme and we're going to go
into that where God is viewed as unfair.
Um his laws can't be kept. Um and this
is the according to the GCT is the whole
point and why we're in the chess match
that we're in. Okay.
Sun, Sabbath school book, lesson 12,
quarter 4, uh, 2013. The cosmic conflict
over God's character. Okay. You can see
where to find the references at. Okay.
Um, some of you might have these in your
attic someplace, right? Uh, here's a
quote. Seventh Day Adventists understand
reality through the biblical concept of
the great controversy between Christ and
Satan. Could you be any more clear?
They understand reality through the
biblical concept. This is the lens
through which it is it is written. It's
right here in your Sabbath school book.
Right? To use a phrase from philosophy,
it is the meta narrative, the grand
overarching story that helps to explain
our world and the things that happen in
it. Um I want to say it was um a quote
earlier. Um uh so I think yeah it might
have been Amazon warrior. I think Amazon
warrior said um that it was the um
it was uh
oh I lost my train of thought. Anyway,
yeah uh it was important
right uh central to this controversy is
the sanctuary which as we have seen
presents a recurrent theme that runs
from the beginning to the end of
salvation history. uh redemption of
humanity through the death of Jesus
properly understood. The sanctuary
message also helps to illustrate God's
character which Satan has been attacking
since the great controversy first began
in heaven. All right, now we're getting
to the juice here, guys. Um
all of that to justify the great
disappointment.
All right, so we read about that a
little bit. Um, we don't believe uh
anything special happened on October
22nd, 1844. Um, I did see uh brother
Peter from SDA Q&A earlier. Uh, so shout
out to you, my man. Uh, God bless you.
And uh I and I don't want to disparage
the dead. I know Bill Johnson just
passed away recently, but um Bill
Johnson, if you are familiar with that
uh old school uh interview on the uh
John Ankerberg show, uh Bill Johnson
defended the SDA church um like a
trooper, I might add, as well. Um
defended the SDA church and their
doctrines on the John Ankerberg show. Um
but when Peter asked him point blank,
"Do you think anything special happened
on October 22nd, 1844?"
Mr. Johnson, Dr. Johnson sat there and
was dead silent.
Yeah, cuz he was at a huge fork in the
road.
Dead silent.
And that was the most telling thing I've
ever seen.
Facts.
This is a man who sat here. Was it 83? I
think it was the Ankerberg show or
whatever the case it was, right? 80
something. 1983 I think it was. um sat
there defended tooth and nail SDA
doctrine, right? Where he could uh
agree, he tried to agree while still
holding the line and he did a great job.
He's a company man through and through.
And when he was asked,
all right, point blank, right? I think
it was last year, wasn't it? Or
something like that, if I'm not
mistaken, a year before, or something
like that. Um did anything
he passed away?
Uh uh no. Well, obviously. Yeah.
Oh, right, right, right. Sorry. Sorry.
With with Peter. um couldn't answer the
question.
Could not answer the question because
he's an honest man. I believe he's an
honest man, right? But I believe that in
his honesty, he recognizes
you can't definitively say anything
happened. And the truth of the matter is
we know nothing happened. Nothing
special,
right?
Okay. And when you have your whole you
base your whole life and livelihood on
something like this, as fickle as this,
you have to go all in,
right? And I hope and pray that he made
the right decisions and the right choice
and he and he acknowledged his mess
beforehand. Okay? I'm not saying his
soul is in danger. I'm not saying he's
in heaven or hell right now. I'm not
saying any of that stuff. It's between
him and God. Yeah. He he has to deal
with it. him and God had to had had to
have that conversation, right? But to be
honest, when you see that, if you see
his face dear in the headlights, look,
man, it's terrible.
It's on the channel, folks. You can
check that out if you want. Mainly just
to I wanted to keep that preserved.
Yeah.
It is like a relic because there's so
much stuff in there where I think they
pulled the wool over Walter's eyes.
Yeah.
And I think he recognized that by the
time that interview comes around because
this is after his book has come out.
Mhm.
Um and you can tell that he didn't he
never had a great controversy worldview.
Yeah.
So they were he should have taken his
own advice and scaled the language
barrier more carefully.
He fell off the barrier
um of his own standard. Not not dogging
Walter Martin. He did an a great gift to
the church,
but he was even able to be bamboozled by
this.
Yeah.
Because they were the whole doct the
questions on doctrine controversy and
all of that sort of stuff. But all of
that to say, um, that's actually on the
channel, folks. You can check that out
if you've never seen that before. And
again, it's really just to preserve that
relic because there's so many telling
signs in that discussion.
I'll tell you I'll tell you this much as
well. Um, so for those who don't know,
um, and maybe it might be a good show,
uh, in the future, Miles, um, for
questions on doctrine, guys, um, to kind
of look into that and how that came
about. Um, you know, uh,
the the fact of the matter is questions
on doctrine was a way that the SCA
church was trying to show the world,
hey, we're not a cult. I know you call
us one, but we're really not. We're
we're Christians just like you, right?
And the beef that it's caused in the
church, like they're saying, we we
didn't approve this. Like the people
were like, we this not what we believe.
We we believe that all these other
people are going to hell. Like, just say
it.
Yeah. And they were, you know, it was it
was one of those things where it caused
more trouble. Um, and the funny thing is
by the time uh we see Walter Martin on
the John Ankerberg show, it's almost 30
years after.
Yep.
Right. So, it was 1950some that came
out. Um, and then 30 years later in the
80s,
then he's like, "Wait a second. This is
not right." Cuz I went back and I looked
and we we checked this out and we're
seeing this and and and and they're
they're they're badmouthing Dez Ford.
They're doing this, that, the other.
Well, and he's like, "Why are people
being fired for upholding questions on
doctrine?
People I'm People are reaching out to me
saying, "Hey, I agree. I I agree with
questions on doctrine, but they're
making me essentially step down."
Yeah.
Well, wait. You just told me that that's
an accurate summation of what you guys
believe. And why is it not in print
anymore? Oh, and over here, I didn't
realize. Why are you guys saying uh
Ellen White is essentially the
infallible interpreter?
Right. Right.
You know, so all this stuff is popping
up. Um, and it's it's it's unraveling at
the seams, right? And mind you, this is
the days before the internet was I don't
even know if the internet was even
invented at that point, you know? So,
all you're hearing is rumors and
innuendo and hey, can we go into the
archives and check this out? Well, that
area is restricted, you know. Uh, you
know, all kinds of stuff there when
people are not being able to uh to uh to
demonstrate um or really I'm sorry, not
demonstrate, but to really research um
uninhibited, right? And uh there was a
time not uh not long ago where the um
the the the archives were hacked and
they were hacked and then exposed. So a
lot of this stuff came out here in a way
that the church was not really wanting
to open up to and now they have to say,
"Okay, well it's there. Y'all can find
it if you want to and then we'll just
play defense."
I have a copy of it.
Yeah. There you go.
Yeah. It's it's the letters and
manuscripts that they just Well, not
just but that they released. And you
have people on the SDA church's website
asking when's volume two coming out, not
realizing, folks, volume one only came
out because they were essentially
threatened,
right?
People essentially hacked the
information. We're like, yo, we're going
to release this if you guys don't. So,
they did. Volume two ain't coming,
unless unless another hack happens. But
nevertheless, yeah, that's that's the
book where she uh you have to get the
physical copy because somebody over at
the White Estates website forgot to
scrub the metadata when they removed the
quotes from the letters where she talks
about God hating wicked little children.
Yeah. Oh my god.
Who are who are disobedient. And they
scrubbed that from the website, the
digital uh archives. Yet, whoever did it
forgot to communicate over that you need
to scrub the metadata because if you put
in the code in the search bar, it will
bring up a preview of what the full
letter quote is, but not the full quote.
And it's in the preview, but then when
you click, it's not there in the actual
letter.
So, you have to get the physical copy to
see what it actually says, which we're
going to be doing a video on that um
relatively soon. But nevertheless, um
Yeah.
Yeah. And this is coming from the people
who keep the commandments um and and
don't bear false witness. But whatever.
Okay, let's move on. Sabbath and Ten
Commandments. What a what a segue.
The law of God. Sabbath and the Ten
Commandments. Let's go. All right. So,
um word association fallacy. Um and that
is to associate a word with the same
single thing regardless of its usage in
context ignoring the semantic range. The
law or law of God is always read as the
ten commandments i.e. Matthew 7 verse12.
The word commandments is always read as
decalogue or the ten commandments. Uh
example John 14 and verse1 15. Okay. So
we're going to do a little Bible study
here in a second guys. Um Matthew 7:12
and 14 uh verse 15. The context is not
referring to the decalogue. Okay. Now,
um Jesus says here in Matthew, uh I'm
sorry, John chapter 14, uh and 20, I'm
sorry, 13-31, excuse me. Um 13:31-
14:21. Um I give you a new commandment.
Love one another. Just as I have loved
you, you must also love one another. Uh
by this people will know that you are my
disciples if you have love for one
another. If you love me, you know that
you keep my commandments. That's John uh
14, right? And I will ask the father and
he'll give you another counselor to be
with you forever. He is the spirit of
truth. The world is unable to receive
him because it doesn't see him or know
him. But you do know him because he
remains with you and will be in you. I
will not leave you as orphans. I'm
coming to you.
In a little while, the world will see me
no longer, but you will see me. Because
I live, you will live too. In that day,
you will know that I am in my father and
you are in me and I am in you. The one
who has my commands and keeps them is
the one who loves me. And the one who
loves me will be loved by my father. I
also will love him and will reveal
reveal him myself to him. Okay. Now, the
command 13:34,
love one another as I have loved you. We
talked about context, guys, right? The
witness Matthew I'm sorry, in in chapter
13:35, the people will know you are a
follower of Christ if you love one
another. And the effect is in Matthew,
I'm sorry, good Lord, John 14 21, the
one who loves other believers loves
Jesus and is therefore loved by the
father and the son Jesus, who will
reveal himself to them. You catch that
guys? Right? So the command is love one
another as I have loved you. If you love
me, keep my commandments. This is the uh
the context. Now if you have I said this
before on my channel and other places um
if you have a red letter um edition
Bible, right, start in uh chapter 13
around uh 20ome maybe 28 27 somewhere in
there. Um when all the red letters
start, okay? Um, aside from
the disciples asking questions and like
uh like replies and uh the the the words
that are put in by the the writer here,
John, um you know, uh all this is all
Jesus talking and the red letters don't
stop as you go into the next chapter,
which is 14. Okay. Um, and so the
context, if you will, of that section,
it's the whole section starting from the
preceding chapter 13 into the next
chapter, subsequent chapter 14. It's all
one conversation.
What some of us have never ever ever
ever ever heard. All right. Um, growing
up SDA, if you grew up when I did,
especially old school, was that chapters
and verses were added later. And because
I didn't understand that before, right,
I would just look for the quoteunquote
address of a particular text. Give me a
book, chapter, and verse. And as and if
I could find that, then I'd basically um
you know, uh uh hopscotch, as Miles like
to say, I like to say, prancing through
the proof texts, right? But, you know,
you kind of work your way from one thing
to the next thing regardless of the
context, right? And proof texting, even
though it was hot stuff back in the uh
18 to ear to mid 1900s, we could say,
right, it's not the way to do correct
Bible study. You have to look at the
context uh for what it's saying. Okay?
Um and we get this all the time. Oh,
you're taking it out of context. And
then this passage, if you love me, keep
my commandments, is part and parcel of
what you see on some of the fundamental
beliefs. Uh
oh. Yeah. Right.
And and brother, I I I just want to
share really quickly here. Um because I
a big mantra on this platform, we're
going to be getting into this in a
couple weeks on the channel more
further, but the mantra on the channel
has been this is not answering
Adventism's private interpretation.
Mhm.
And so just to piggyback off of what
you're saying, I want to cite here, we
could look at all sorts of people.
What CNB just said, folks, is not just
CNB shooting off the cuff. It's not just
his private interpretation.
Notice what Christosm says. Golden
mouth.
We're talking fourth century here. His
homalies
quote this is him. His homalies number
75 on John 14:15-17 and SDA. Yes, we
know that this is not scripture.
That's not why this is being cited. So
don't use the well that's not the Bible.
Yes, we're aware. We're aware the
purpose of showing this is to show that
what CNB said is not his own private
interpretation. Christians have
understood this about this specific
passage.
Chrysum is preaching on this. If you
want to say Chrysm's a heresetic,
whatever, openly state that, okay, let
us know that you think John Chrissum is
a heretic. Okay? Because this was his
comments on it and I think he's
qualified to speak on this. Just look up
and study chrostm. Okay. He says, quote,
"We need everywhere works and actions."
So notice, are Christians saying, "No,
you just sit by idol if you disagree
with what we say."
Right?
No. That's the false dilemma fallacy.
Yeah.
You guys have misplaced. You have the
cart before the horse thinking that the
works have some different some role that
they don't actually have. That's the
problem. Not works themselves. But he
continues, "Not a mere show of words.
For to say and to promise is easy for
anyone but to act is not equally easy. I
mean who could disagree with this. Why
have I made these remarks? So now he
answers why he starts by saying this.
This is a sermon. That's what homaly
means folks. This was him preaching
through the text.
Because there are many at this time who
say that there they fear and love God
but in their works show the contrary.
But God requires that love which is
shown by works. Wherefore he said to the
disciples, if you love me, keep my
commandments. Notice what he breaks down
here. For after he had told them,
whatsoever you shall ask, I will do it
that they might not deem the mere asking
to be availing.
Chrysum is breaking down the context
here. He's explaining that there's a
conversation going on between Jesus and
the disciples.
So after saying what he said previously
about the spirit being given or rather
what you ask I'll do it they might deem
the mere asking to be availing just
simply asking without their actual
actions.
Mhm.
If you love me keep my commandments.
There's actions involved there. So he's
pointing out that they could have been
tempted to say well uh we don't have to
do any you know if I just ask he'll just
do it. Well, no, you have to act in
accordance with the request. He added,
if you love me, then he says, I will do
it. And since it was likely that they
would be troubled when they heard that,
I go to the father. So what? Because
they were they were troubled. If you
listen, they're confused about him going
to the father. Yet how are we going to
function as your disciples in the world
if you are not physically with us? Mhm.
So when they heard I go to the father,
he tells them to be troubled now is not
to love.
To love is to obey my words. I've given
you a commandment that you love one
another. Quoting back to what you
mentioned in chapter 13. Because this is
all one dialogue.
The chapter and verse divisions are a
1500th edition to give you an idea of
where you're citing from, not to build
entire doctrines off of. So, Chrostm
recognizes that this is a flow of a
single conversation that started back in
chapter 13. And the command that was
given was that you love one another,
that you do so to each other as I have
done to you. This is love to obey these
my words, and to yield to him who is the
object of your love. Close quote. So,
all of that to say, you're not just
talking out the side of your neck. This
isn't CMBB's own private interpretation
or something like that. What he just
laid out is what people have understood
for a long time.
I just wanted to share that aspect
because again, I think it's important
for people to understand
that's not what you're doing. You're not
just like, well, this is just me just
coming up with this.
Yeah. All right. So again, when we're
looking at that, the command, love one
another as I've loved you. The witness
people will know you're a disciple of
Christ or a follower of Christ if you
love one another. And the effect is the
one who loves others, other believers
love Jesus and therefore is loved by God
uh the father and the son and will
reveal they will reveal himself to him.
All right? And of course the spirit
comes in a little bit later in John, but
we love that sort of thing. Okay? Uh and
so the context is not referring to the
decalogue. If you love me, keep my
commandments is not a reference to the
ten commandments, guys. Okay. All right.
So, back to ministry. Um, a different uh
edition right here, November 2, 2006,
page 27. Um, and this is uh a the
wording um of the role of the Ten
Commandments in public life. All right.
Um, and this is what their statement
was. Okay. Here's the statement. Quote,
"The 7th Day Adventist Church applauds
interest in the role of the Ten
Commandments in public life. Uh, the
decalogue as given on Mount Si is a
reflection of God's character."
Oh boy. Okay. Uh, that would be Jesus.
But let's carry on. Uh, it contains
universal principles of morality and dis
it describes our relationship to God and
our fellow human beings. For 7th Day
Adventists, obedience to the Ten
Commandments represents the foundational
expression of love and gratitude to God
for his gift of salvation.
Um, obedience to Christ would do that.
But let's continue. We obey the law not
as a means of salvation. Untrue, but as
a response to God's grace, demonstrating
most convincingly through Christ's death
on our behalf. The quote continues, "The
Ten Commandments provides a moral
compass in an age of relativism. Through
God's law, the Holy Spirit convicts us
of sin and brings us to a sense of utter
helplessness." And here is the
switcheroo. The law of God is the
instrument by which the spirit calls us
to repentance. Okay. The switcheroo is
it goes from the commandments and then
assumes that it is part and parcel or
can be interchanged with um the law of
God. The ten commandments, the law of
God. Did you see? Did you catch that? It
is the instrument by which the spirit
calls us to repentance. Okay. It is all
it also has a teaching function
revealing eternal principles for
righteousness that contribute to the
development of our character in the
likeness of our savior. Consequently, we
comprehend more clearly how to serve
others and our God." End quote. All
right. Um, your thoughts, brother?
Sorry. They have latched on to here. Um,
so so and I mentioned this folks this
past week and I'm going to continue
hammering on this on this platform. um
they have latched on to other people
namely at that time Puritans
um who were popular from the previous
generation to the 19th century the 18th
century Puritans um people like Thomas
Watson which I referenced LA on last
week's stream this movement has latched
on to those individuals which is where
they're getting some of the the the
wording and ideas around uh and these
things actually I guess weren't unique
to the Puritans the Puritans were just
continuing to build on where others
before them had left off. Chrissum
actually has a decent amount of stuff
just because there's so much stuff out
there um from him because he was so
prolific. Um you he gets into this as
well, but the Puritans were big on um
the discussion around the proper use of
the law. So they've taken things like uh
the decalogue as given on Mount Si is a
reflection of God's character. Well,
you're going to find reformed people
that say stuff like that. And then the
SDA church will want to point to those
people to say, "Well, see the these
people over here you would consider to
be valid Christians." They were saying
this, too. No, they didn't mean what you
guys mean. They weren't filtering it
through the great controversy theme.
That that's not what they they didn't
mean what Ellen White mean or or sorry,
what the SDA church here means in this
magazine. They mean something
fundamentally different because it
communicates where it's necessary for
their great controversy theme to work.
That the Ten Commandments are something
up in heaven that Lucifer began
attacking and accusing. That's what all
of this is coming from. That's not what
the reformers were saying. That's not
what the Puritans were saying. Now,
there are Christians that disagree on
these points. I don't think CNB
necessarily would agree with these
individuals, for example. But that
doesn't make him not a Christian. That's
insight into how there's a fundamental
difference here between what Christians
believe and something that unites all of
them despite having differences on
certain areas. Because what they meant
when they said that the Decalogue was a
reflection of God's character was that
that God's not a liar, for example, it's
the opposite of what God is. God's not a
liar. He's not a murderer. He's not a
thief, etc. That's what they meant.
That's not only what the SDA church
means. The SDA church has to have it as
a part of this pre-Earth origin story.
That's why they're ultimately believing
it and claiming that. So that's what
they have going on here. It's not the
same thing as the people they'll want to
point to because Joseph Bates, for
example, came out of the Presbyterian
world. They liked the the Presbyterian,
which I'm a Presbyterian. So they like
the Presbyterian understanding of the
law. So they've pulled that into their
system because Joseph Bates was a part
of systematizing the system. Him, Jo,
Joseph or uh James White, Jose Joseph
Bates, Uriah Smith, those individuals.
Well, those people were coming from the
three backgrounds that I mentioned
earlier. And so this is where their
understanding of the law is ultimately
coming from. And they'll try to latch on
to other people's arguments when those
people did not mean the same thing that
you're meaning because they didn't have
the great controversy theme.
But also, no, they don't understand the
proper use of the law and they don't
understand covenant theology. Now,
there's people out there that do not
agree with covenant theology and that's
fine. It doesn't make them lost or or
whatnot. But those of us that do,
they've latched on to that aspect as
well. But see, they do not understand
law gospel distinction.
That's the reason why there can't be a
different understanding. So, for
example, Lutheran and Presbyterians,
going back to the Reformation, Lutheran
and Presbyterians have a different
understanding about certain aspects of
the law of God. Yet, what they're
completely united on is that the law is
not the gospel.
There's a law gospel distinction. I just
did a video on this a couple weeks ago.
You guys can check that out. It's not
just the idea of the law being the ten
commandments. No, no. The law gospel
distinction is something specific in how
to handle and understand scripture. All
Christians understand that, which is
what unites us. And there's a there's
able to be differing opinions around
certain aspects or mechanics of the law.
But I just say that to say when they
bring stuff up like this, one of the
common arguments that they like to use
is to point to other people, well, all
the reformers were historicists. That's
what they used to support historicism.
Well, all the reformers were. Or, well,
John Wesley said this for sinless
perfectionism. or they just try to latch
on to these different groups and say,
"Well, we're firmly in that tradition
when no, you're not because it's being
distilled through the great controversy
thing."
Oh, I was muted. Yeah, exactly. Exactly
right, brother. Um,
I'm just look I was looking at the chat
here and
oh my um
you may want to check that out at some
point. uh last couple minutes here, bro.
Unbelievable. Uh Fred, I'm praying for
you, bro. All right, moving on. Okay,
and I mean that in a a non-facious way,
by the way. So, I I really mean that.
Okay. Um
uh I This is weird. I got a little I got
a blue tint over my screen here. Uh
uh Miles, I'm not sure what's going on.
Um the Sabbath. Okay. Uh hopefully I can
read all of it. The Sabbath will be the
great test of loyalty. For it is the
point of truth, especially controverted,
when the final test shall be brought to
bear upon men, when then the line of
distinction will be drawn between those
who serve God and those who serve him
not. Um, the Sabbath will be the great
test of loyalty. And it's it's it's
strange because, you know, according to
scriptures, right? Um,
according to scripture, um, it's Christ.
It it is it is Jesus that's the the the
dividing line between those who love,
uh, the Lord and those who don't, right?
It it is it it is it is loyalty to him.
Um, and um,
M, do you see that blue uh, tint over
the screen on your
I do not, so I don't know what on your
end is is causing that. So, sorry about
that.
I don't know either. I can I can uh take
it out and try to run it back again
here. I can do that.
Yeah, if you want. U this is another
area, folks, where again I talked about
this with Ted Wilson's annual annual
annual council.
There you go. This is another area where
they've latched on to uh other people's
ideas, namely people like Thomas Watson
and the Puritans and their arguments
missing the forest for the trees which
is new creation to then add on to it the
aspect they need for their system.
In this case, the Sabbath is the great
test of loyalty. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa.
What? No, it's not. What are you talking
about? No, it's not. The Sabbath is the
go. Oh, then you realize again this is
one of the pillar doctrines.
Oh, there was a vision about the seventh
day Sabbath. Oh, but wait, it didn't
come from you guys.
It came from a track from Seventh Day
Baptist.
That's right. Sister Sister Preston.
Rachel Oaks.
Yeah, which I I erroneously mentioned
her earlier during uh the the state of
the dead. I was confusing it with the
the Sabbath. Yes. Rachel Ugs Preston.
And no, it's not the test of loyalty
between who is truly following God and
who is not.
The true test is who believes the
gospel.
Yeah.
Of Jesus Christ. It's his gospel. So in
order to have the right gospel, you have
to have the correct God. And it's his
gospel. That is because those people
that believe that, as Paul tells us in
Ephesians 1, are given the spirit as a
down payment, a seal.
The true body of Christ is all people in
all places at all times who are born
again, united to Jesus Christ by faith.
Not pre only Presbyterians, not only
Baptists, etc. It's all of those who are
united to Jesus Christ by faith. That's
the church. And those people are the
people who believe the true gospel and
have been born again. They're then
united to Jesus Christ. And so, uh, all
of that to say that doesn't have
anything to do with the Sabbath.
Furthermore, the Sabbath is a part of
law, not gospel.
Right?
The Sabbath is not the gospel. That's
not the good news. That's not what the
good news is. That's a theological
doctrine that falls under the category
of law. Again, showcasing they don't
understand the law gospel distinction at
all.
Right. Okay. Um, we're back, guys. Um,
wow. God has given man a complete rule
of life in his law. Obeyed, he shall
live by it. Through the merits of
Christ, transgressed, it has the power
to condemn. The law sends men to Christ
and Christ points them back to the law.
It's so strange to me that she would say
something like this. Um, and Christ
says, "Come unto me all ye that labor
and are heavy laden, and I will give you
rest. Take my yoke upon me and learn of
me for my meek and low in heart and you
shall find rest for your souls. Right
now, this is funny because that's
Matthew 11, the end of Matthew 11.
Correct. Um, and then if you read the
next chapter,
Matthew records two back-to-back
incidences of Jesus and the disciples
breaking the Sabbath. Okay.
Funny how that works. Okay. Um, and if
we're taking the inspiration of the Holy
Spirit seriously, uh, the the
inspiration of the in scripture
seriously, which I do, um, that's not by
accident,
okay? For Christ, Matthew to to to
record Christ as saying, "Come unto me
all you that are le he le he le he le he
le he le he le he le he le he le he levy
uh heavy laden and labor uh and I will
give you rest." Right? Then there's no
way then that was by accident. Okay? And
then we see Christ healing and then
rubbing grain and picking uh plucking
grain um and he's saying he's Lord of
the Sabbath and all this kind of stuff.
And the funny thing is when we see uh
opt or quotes like uh in 7th day
adventist circles well if Jesus is the
lord of the sabbath then who's lord of
Sunday you know um Jesus is so
said all authority is given to me right
um at the at the resurrection all
authority um you know he has all the
authority right so he owns everything he
has owned everything uh if you ever read
the first couple verses of the gospel of
John right there's nothing created that
he didn't make. Okay? So, a he's not a
created being. Sorry for you non people.
Um and then two, he is responsible for
all of these things that are created in
in the physical realm. So, uh and even
in and even the invisible realm, you
know what I mean? So, he's created all
these spirit beings that are we know as
angels and so forth like that, right?
So, we're not we're not in a situation
where um Jesus is just lord of the
Sabbath and then Satan has everything
else under his control. That's not how
that works, right? Um, something amazing
happened at the cross. And I think a lot
of people don't realize it. Some people
have truncated uh Christ's ministry to a
means of an end and Jesus died so it
made it possible for me to live a
sinless life. That's not how that works,
right? He he he he fulfilled both ends
of the bargain. He had to be uh fully
God and fully man in order to meet both
uh uh uh uh parts of the covenant of the
old covenant there. Okay? And so that's
we'll get to that another time. But
yeah, this is this is this is bad
situation. Yeah,
it's just crazy, man. Like this is a
perfect example. I love this quote.
I love this quote. There are it's just
it's said so plainly. They can try the
Oh, that's out of context.
No, you're not Protestant.
This is another area where they need to
be honest.
Yeah.
No, don't appeal to the Puritans. Don't
appeal to the reformers. Don't appeal to
my spiritual ancestors to try and say,
"Well, they they they would have agreed
with this." No, they would not have.
No. No.
They would have agreed with the first
part that the law points a person to
Christ. That Ray Comfort does this, for
example, where he's out street
witnessing and he's like, "Have you told
a lie?" Right?
Have you ever stolen?
But that's ultimately to lead them to
the gospel.
Caroline,
not to lead them to Jesus. For him to
then turn you around and say, "Go back
to the law."
Right? which is what their art shows
that you're going to see later.
That's correct.
No, no. It's like it we've talked about
this before, you and I have, how it's
like if swinging a miss were a
theological system. It's just like,
oh yeah, the the law so far.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah. The law. It's like
Yeah. Oh man, the law sends people to
Christ. Yeah. Oh, and Christ points them
back to the law.
Oh, it's just like so close yet
completely backwards. Completely
backwards. No law does the law sends you
to Christ where you stay. You stay in
Christ, not turning away to some other
thing because then if you disagree with
them on this, they say, "Well, then
you're you disagree with this. You
disagree with obedience." No, we just
told you earlier what the obedience was
back in John 14, for example.
Clearly not against obedience. We're
we're commanded to love one another.
We're commanded to believe the gospel,
etc. All sorts of things. We're not
against any of that. We're against you
saying that the law points you to Christ
and then he just points you back to the
law.
That'd be an endless That would be an
endless loop, right? you know, because
you have to keep going back to him and
then he just continues to point you back
to the
like uh until your character's right,
you know, get those uh get rid of those
ballparks and get the leanies. You know
what I mean?
Get your get your ace ace points,
right? It's crazy. All right, moving on.
All right. Uh man who has defaced the
image of God in his soul by a corrupt
life cannot by mere human effort affect
a radical change in himself. He must
accept the provisions of the gospel. He
must be reconciled to God through
obedience to his law and faith in Jesus.
Wait a minute. Wait a minute. Wait a
minute.
Wait a minute. Right there.
I I mean there there's no way to
reconcile this quote, folks. It's a
false gospel. You're not reconciled by
obedience. And recognizing this does not
therefore mean that you don't believe
that obedience will follow in a
Christian's life.
You recognize though that even your
obedience cannot add to what Jesus has
already done. You don't meet the
standard. It's not get a doover at the
old covenant again. And now that Jesus
is in heaven in a sanctuary, I can
continually try over and over to where I
eventually get to a point where I'm
keeping him perfectly.
Yeah.
You don't understand the gospel.
Sorry, all Christians agree on this
Adventists. This is not like, "Oh, only
Baptists believe that or that's what
Calvinists say." No, you're you're
missing it. It's not systematic
theology. It's people that recognize
Christ alone is enough.
Yeah.
You can't add anything to it. And that
does change a person when that really
clicks and they understand that and they
begin to want to obey because they're
born again now. They're made a new
creature in Christ, which does lead to
different behavior. But that change in
behavior is not like, well, now you're
on probation.
And because the reality is, folks, is
when you're born again, you're a
spiritual babe in Christ. It takes time
to mature in the faith. It takes time to
learn more about where you're falling
short because you as a born again
believer, you understand how deep sin
runs. It's not this real surface level
like, well, I didn't go to the store and
steal anything today. I didn't bow down
to a statue. Uh it's all this very I
didn't commit adultery in my, you know,
my physical activity. Yeah, but Jesus
expounded upon the law, folks. Not to
say, now here's how high the standard
really is. So if you don't meet that,
you're not going to be saved. No, he's
expounding upon the law to point people
ultimately to the gospel to reveal, look
how high the standard actually is. Which
is why in the Lord's prayer, he taught
the posture that Christians are supposed
to take daily.
Yeah. God forgive me a sinner.
Even in my thought life, Jesus was
obedient literally in thought word,
deed, and motive 24/7.
That's right.
That's the standard. You're not there.
You're deceiving yourself if you think
that.
You need to cling to Christ every day
and keep your eyes on the Lord Jesus.
Not inward, not on your own. Because
when you behold him, you'll become more
like him.
Correct? You just need to keep your eyes
on Christ, trust in Christ, and that
Christ is going to never leave or
forsake you like he's promised. Believe
his word,
right? Um, and uh, he says that he he
that's begun a good word in uh, excuse
me, he that began a good work in you uh,
will perform it to the day of Jesus
Christ. And I have to quote King James
because that's where I grew up with, so
forgive me if that offends you. Um, I'm
not KJV only, by the way. But um, it's
one of those things that we have to know
we're all works in progress. Um, and
we're being sanctified daily, you know,
by Christ as as long as we're, uh,
submitted to him, you know. So, just,
uh, please guys, uh, take your time with
that. All right, moving on. Okay. Um,
let's go to the next thing. I'll try and
bust through the rest of this here when
you get done. Um, for the highest good
of his creatures, God has given a
perfect law, a law that man's demands
perfect obedience. God compels no one to
obey his law.
He
the law demands perfect obedience but
God compels no one to obey his law.
Okay, good. He leaves men free to decide
what they do. Will obey and receive the
word word of obedience or disobey and
receive the punishment of transgression.
So I guess Romans 7 doesn't have
anything to do with anything here. But
um
well just notice how again you're on
this pillar. This is a part of the
system. This is their understanding of
the law.
Yeah.
This is a part of their gospel
supposedly. M
this is how you're reconciled to God.
They said earlier in the Ministry
magazine that salvation is a gift.
That's not what she says here. She says
it's a reward for obedience.
A reward is something received for an
achievement
or something that you've done in and not
necessarily compensation but as um for
lack of a better term for compensation
for your achievement etc. That's not
what salvation is. And right here it
says the law demands perfect obedience.
And then she talks about obedience being
rewarded with salvation, which means
Adventists, you can say, "Oh, she never
verbatim said anywhere, if you don't
confess every single sin and you're
sinlessly perfect." "Oh, so she didn't
teach teach sinless perfectionism
because she never said that verbatim."
It's right here. Perfect obedience, not
trying your best.
Sinless perfection
facts. And we're going to get into that
actually the next couple slides, too, I
think. Right. So, um, let's get to going
here. Um, the law. Okay. Um, Jesus
raised the cover of the Oh, yeah. And I
beheld the tables of stone on which the
ten commandments were given were
written. I was amazed. This is in
vision, by the way. Um, as and I saw the
fourth commandment in the very center of
the ten precepts with a soft halo of
light encircling it, said the angel. It
is only one of the 10 which defines the
living God who created the heavens and
the earth and all things that are in.
When the foundations of the earth were
laid, then was also laid the foundation
of the Sabbath. Um this is just complete
fiction, right? Uh absolute fiction, you
know. Um, she goes on to say in this
particular vision that all of the angels
were staring um with reverent awe at the
commandments,
not the Lord,
not the word, not the spirit. They're
staring at the law.
And it would have done a really what a
lot a lot of good to read re uh Romans
1,
right? Because Paul goes on in Romans 1
and 2 to talk about the Gentiles who
weren't given the law still know that
there's a creator because of natural law
written upon their conscience.
It says nothing about them knowing the
Sabbath
and that being the only one of the ten
commandments that identifies the living
God,
right?
Well, no.
Defines the God, you know, like
Yeah. No, even the Gentiles have natural
law which uh which is essentially
general revelation for them to know that
there is a creator.
Mhm.
So no, the Sabbath is not. Again, this
is what I I always say. They latch on to
like other people's beliefs on things
and then they'll try and point to them
to say, "Well, this person held to this
over here." They did not. But the people
you're going to point to did not say
that there's a soft halo of light around
a ten commandments in heaven. This is
the great controversy theme speaking.
This is not the Bible.
Right.
Oh man. I was shown that if the true
Sabbath had been kept, there would never
have been an infidel or an atheist.
Really? The observance of the Sabbath
would have preserved the world from
idolatry.
Wow.
the Sabbath. If the true Sabbath had
been kept, there would never been an
infidel. Amazing, amazing stuff, right?
Um and mind you,
she says in another place that all
heaven is keeping the Sabbath, right?
So, how does that explain the great
controversy theme? They didn't keep all
the I'll keep the Sabbath and the third
of the angels that fell didn't keep the
Sabbath. That's what happened. Okay,
carry on.
Well, not just that, but sun and moon
are necessary. See, this is the problem,
too. CNB which I don't know how much you
know about this but like
again they try to point to Puritans and
reformers who said for example that the
fourth commandment is a revelation of
God's character
but what they meant is that the core of
that commandment in their understanding
was that a due portion of time is due to
worship the one true God he's worthy of
that
right
not the seventh day they understood the
seventh day to be a pattern because
again like you mentioned earlier there
was a lunar calendar they weren't
following following a Roman calendar,
right?
It was every seven days from a memorial.
That was the the the point. And it was
that the one true God is due a due
portion of worship. But the SDAs have
now taken that to then apply it in their
great controversy theme to say, well,
even the angels are keeping the seventh
day Sabbath as though there's time in
heaven. Oh, right. Because the great
controversy theme talks about God not
being timeless. That's supposedly
arisatilian philosophy.
That's platonic, right? or these other
excuses because they have to define it
through the great controversy theme to
where they then make the day an idol
which is what it is in the movement is
the day not an idol like a 24hour
rotation around the sun
becomes almost like a divine thing where
it has like divine characteristics
because it in and of itself is eternal
correct
this pattern of seven the day that they
call Sabbath which is Saturday according
to this naming system we have.
But that that specific rotation, it's
like almost at 12:01,
there's like a a just something starts
that's like a divine thing. That's what
they've drawn that out to when No,
that's not what other people are saying.
No. And um one of the things that uh I
find fascinating now um that that I've
been out for so long and it just it it
it is it is mindboggling to me because
I've realized as you said uh Miles that
the Sabbath actually has become an idol
uh to the Seventh Day Adventist Church
and maybe it was the whole time and I
just didn't know. Um but think about it
guys um
for uh quote unquote Sunday keepers. I
don't know what the Sunday keeper is, by
the way. But for us who go to church on
Sundays, I have yet to hear
a song that praises Sunday.
Yeah.
In the way that don't forget the Sabbath
and welcome, welcome ever. Welcome,
blessed day. Never,
never have I heard such things, right?
And you can day of all the week the best
album of eternal rest all this stuff
like you can go down the list and talk
about um day is dying in the west all
this stuff you know how how the Sabbath
is exalted.
There are songs to uh talk about its
beauty and things that should be
attributed to God are attributed to the
Sabbath. You know the
that's what I was gonna say is like
Christian
our uh
all of that. Yeah. It should be going to
Christ.
Yeah.
That's where the substances
not in the day. I don't care what you
call it. They they love to do the whole
like uh
Sunday for the sun,
right?
Argument which is like oh okay so you
worship Saturn then? Well no it's called
Sabbath,
right?
That's what they always tell. Well, no.
It's called that's called Sabbath. Oh,
right. But we're you're ascribing Sunday
to us because that was ascribed. I don't
care what you call it because that's not
the point. Jesus is the point. And
that's the memorial of when we celebrate
when he accomplished redemption.
Amen.
Because that's who we're there for.
We're there for Jesus. Jesus is better.
That's right. And that's the whole theme
of Hebrews, uh, guys. So, check that
out. You know, again, if you don't have
to watch it on my channel, just read on
your own. We don't care, you know. Um,
just Yeah, check it out. um you know uh
find read it you know if you can read uh
the book of Hebrews cover to cover uh or
the book uh chapter 1 through the end uh
do that and then go back and study um
you'll be surprised same thing with
Galatians do it please all right moving
on all right Ellen also says we should
make efforts to call together large
congregations to hear the words of the
min gospel minister and those who preach
the word of the Lord should speak the
truth they should bring their hearers as
it were to the foot of Si and I to
listen to the words spoken by God amid
amid scenes of awful grandeur. I would
rather go to the foot of Calvary.
My friends, um I've said before in
multiple places and multiple times that
if people are running past Calvary to
get to Sinai, something's off in your
theology.
That's just how it goes. Again, if you
read the book of Galatians, um Paul
makes the analogy of Sinai being like
Hagar.
Okay. And and Calvary uh being like uh
uh um uh Sarah, you know, or vice versa,
Sarah being like uh Calvary, you know,
and you don't want to go with the bond
woman,
you know, um
in the book of Hebrews, Hebrews 12.
Yeah.
It compares Zion
with Sinai and how Sinai was a scene of
awful grandeur.
what she's literally saying right here,
which the people were so afraid they as
they were too afraid to approach God,
right?
The author uses that in Hebrews after
telling us that the believer in the new
covenant doesn't have to have that fear
because they're in Christ,
right? And we can go boldly before the
grace,
correct? Hebrews 10. So then he compares
Mount Si with Mount Zion and talks about
how that was a scene of awful grandeur
and fear. Whereas we can boldly approach
Mount Zion and we don't have to have
fear. It's funny that Ted said in the uh
annual council that he wants you to look
forward. We're pointing forward. No,
you're not. Everything's going back.
It's always back.
Always back. Yeah. Oh, man. This is This
is awful, guys. And I hope you're paying
attention here, guys. Um, let's go to
the next thing. Yeah. This is the
problem.
SDA art. It's Jesus pointing to the
commandments. Go to Sinai. What kind of
Christ do you know that says, "Come to
me. I'll give you rest. If you don't
believe I'm he, you'll die in your sins.
It says, "No, no, no. Forget all that
what I said. Go to Sinai. You got it.
Moses will take care of you." What? Some
tell them Jesus sent you. What? Stop it.
Okay. Sinless perfectionism. Almost
done, guys. Um, victory over sin. Okay,
that's pillar number six. And it's
really about sinless perfectionism. And
I've heard people on multiple times, uh,
multiple places say, "Oh, we don't teach
sinless perfectionism." Yeah, you do.
Okay. Um, and that's necessary for you
to uh function through this great
controversy theme. Okay, let's look at a
couple of uh uh passages here. Do you
want to jump in before we do that,
Miles? Or
Well, I was just going to say remember
the quote we saw earlier, perfect
obedience.
Yes. Yes.
Because the law of God pillar, the law
of God pillar, the previous one,
perfect obedience.
Right. Okay. All right. What is this
everlasting gospel? This gospel is
called victory over sin. that as
Christians we can live a sinless and
perfect life by the indwelling Christ of
P of indwelling power of Christ. Pardon
me guys, it's late. All right. Um let's
move on. A few quotes from the SDA
pioneers uh and their views on sinless
perfection and Christ nature. All right.
This is ML Andreas. He says, uh, the
final demonstration of what the gospel
can do in and for humanity is still in
the future. Christ showed the way. He
took a human body and in that body
demonstrated the power of God. Men are
to follow his example.
His example
and prove that what God did in Christ,
he can do in every human being that who
submits to him. Let's ask a question
here. Is Jesus Christ the word of God
who is with God and was God in the
beginning according to John John 1
vers1.
If he is, then it's not that God was
doing something special in Christ. It is
God manifest in the flesh who was doing
this thing. Okay? It's not that Jesus is
just some glorified example of, oh, if I
can do what Simon says. You know, if I
can do it, you can do it, too. Right?
Um, and if you have a diminished view of
Christ, he is little more than an
example of how to how to how that his
law can be kept. And that's the whole
point of uh the great controversy theme.
Go ahead, brother.
Yeah. They do not understand at all
that, and again, this gets into their
understanding of man's nature, original
sin. Mhm.
Um they do not understand that Christ
did not have a was not born dead in
trespasses and sins like the rest of us.
Mhm.
There's a fundamental there was a
fundamental different aspect in really
two regards to the nature of Christ. The
fact that he was both human and divine.
100% human 100% divine hypothetic union.
Yeah.
As well as he was not born dead in
trespasses and sins. He was the second
Adam. he wasn't after the parogeny of
Adam.
And so because of that, he was
fundamentally different than us in
certain aspects. They'll then try and
say, "Well, then that that and they
assume the great controversy theme with
this." Well, then that would mean that
of course we can't be like he was,
right? That's the point.
That's the point.
That's the point. You're you're not
Christ. And the the purpose of the
gospel is the good news that Christ is
enough. And yes, we do seek to live holy
lives, but the standard is ultimate
perfection. And if you've broken the law
once, there's no provision for doovers.
That's right.
There's no provision for doovers. You're
in Adam and you need transferred into
the kingdom of light from the kingdom of
darkness. And only Christ can do that.
Not Christ plus your obedience after
that. That then keeps you in the
kingdom. God chastises his children.
Hebrews uh 12 after actually talking
about I I believe it's right after
talking about the comparison between
Zioni and Zion. But nevertheless, God
chastises his children. He doesn't
disown them and it's not a constant
going back and forth back and forth like
you were mentioning earlier. So,
uh no, he's not just a glorified
example,
right? Amen. Um let's and this is
probably one of the more egregious parts
right here. Um the world is awaiting
this demonstration. Romans 8:19. uh when
it has been accomplished, the end will
come. God will have fulfilled his plan.
He will have shown himself true and
Satan a liar. His government will stand
vindicated. That's the whole point,
guys, of the great controversy theme.
And we'll get into some more details in
a little bit. Um in the last generation,
God gives the final demonstration that
men can keep the law of God and that
they can live without sinning. Show me
one person. There's eight plus billion
people on this planet right now. Show me
one who's walking without sin. Just one,
please. And I'll show you first John
chapter 1 uh verses 8 and verse 10. But
carry on. All right. God leaves nothing
undone to make the demonstration
complete. The only limitation uh put
upon Satan is that he may not kill the
saints of God. He may tempt them. He may
harass and threaten them. And he does
his best, but he fails. He cannot make
them sin. I don't believe that the devil
can make you do it either. They stand
the test and God put on put his seal
upon them. Through the last generation
of saints, God stands finally
vindicated.
Through them, he defeats Satan and wins
his case. again. What in the world kind
of God do y'all believe in that he has
to sit in the witness stand and he's on
trial?
H who gets to sit in the judgment seat?
Are the unfollowing worlds the jury box?
Is that how that works?
They love to try and say, "Well, no.
It's God choosing to be this way so that
we can see that we can trust him." What
do you mean? You have to be able to see.
You have to, again, this gets into them
thinking the millennium is like a
thousand years of fact-checking God.
I've even heard Steven Boore say when
talking about that that it's going to be
a time where they can go, "Oh, okay. We
can trust him."
Right? Like really,
when you're in the millennial reign,
right?
What? And my my thing is like, how can
you how can you live um in and we're
talking about these uh beings that are
are with God right now, right? Are you
telling me that all of them do not trust
God?
Yeah, for them too,
right? They don't they don't believe God
right now. That they kind of trust him.
That's unbelief, folks. That's unbelief.
It is sin.
What do you mean that they're fallen?
Right. It is sin. Exactly right.
And you want you you want us to believe
that finite human beings in their most
fallen state because remember the
further we go from Adam the more
depraved and decrepit and messy we are
right
they argue they argue was he 4,000 years
removed from Adam such that he had that
degradation on him or was he just like
that Adam the original Adam
right you know and so mind you we're the
ones that are supposed to be able to get
it right and go to heaven and uh and and
during the thousand years Right. Be able
to factch checkck God
and then say, "Yeah, you know what? Just
and true are all your ways. You're
right. Yep. Yep. You got it. You're
right." Mhm. It was
and and that they can trust what he's
about to do with the second resurrection
and the obliteration
of the wicked and whatnot to know that
he's just in doing what he's doing.
This is unbelievable.
It's like, dude, it is like
anthropocentrism, like man- centeredness
on steroids.
Yeah. Unbelievable. All right, moving
on. EJ Wagner, in all our Christian
experience, we have left little
loopholes along here and there for sin.
We have never dared to come to that
place where we would believe that the
Christian life should be a sinless life.
We have not dared to believe or preach
it. But in that case, we cannot preach
the law of God fully. Why not? Because
we do not understand the power of
justification by faith. In other words,
my question for this is um we can't get
to the point where we can believe that
the Christian life is be sinless um and
we can't preach it.
So, are you preaching that you are
walking around here sinless EJ Wagner?
Does E did EJ Wagner sin? Was he walking
around without sin when he passed away?
Facts.
How about Ellen White?
How about GI Butler? How about James
Springer White? How about Jane Andrews?
How about any of these people? How about
Grandmama and them? Right. Are they
without sin right now?
And we Miles, I'm sure you've had those
conversations with people. Yeah, of
course. I I don't sin. I haven't sinned
in three weeks.
Yeah. And then we start And then we
start getting specific and they get
skittish.
Right. Right. Right. Right. Right.
Right. Did when you were at work, was
literally every second of your time
devoted to your employer such that you
weren't robbing them of any time while
on the clock,
right?
All of a sudden, it's like, whoa, well,
I wasn't thinking about that. Yeah,
that's the point. That's what Jesus was
saying when he was expounding upon the
law.
Goodness gracious. EJ Wagner. All right,
we're going to see him again later.
Jones, uh, Christ is to be in us just as
God was in him. There's a problem right
there. I hope you I don't know if you
guys noticed that, but Christ is to be
in us just as God was in him. And his
character is to be in us just as God was
in him. It is the cooperation of the
divine and the human, the mystery of God
in you and me. That is the third angel's
message. And again, I have to ask, what
is the nature of this Christ that you're
preaching? Miles brought it up earlier,
you know, about the uh uh Michelle says
I'm at work putting tabs on my Bible,
right? But yeah, the nature of Christ,
okay, is he fully God and fully man or
is he something else,
right? And if we're in a position where
we can't trust uh that Christ is fully
God and fully man, then yeah, God is in
Christ and they're separate.
Okay? And this is the kind of thing I'm
not and I'm not I'm preaching on oneness
Jesus either by the way. I'm a
trinitarian. Um and so this is the kind
of thing that we're getting to some
hairy um uh christologology here that's
not biblical. Okay. And when we look at
these things uh what at Jones is saying
here and what some of the other people
are going to be saying as we look at the
rest of these quotes here. Um you're
really asking for a Jesus that's not or
or believing in a Jesus that's not the
one that's in scripture.
Okay. So you got to be careful
Jesus made in the image of man,
right? You know in Jesus Christ at Jones
again he was in sin as he was in sinful
flesh. Wait a minute. God has
demonstrated before the universe that he
can so take possession of sinful flesh
as to manifest his own presence, his
power and his glory instead of sin
manifesting itself. Wow,
dude. When I first read this, I I
literally had to do like a triple take
on
I like did the old thing like you see in
the movie like look completely away from
the book or and like look back type
thing like did he actually say this
in Jesus Christ as he was in sinful
flesh?
Dude, I was just doing research on this
this past week or just further research
on this to see some of the the modern
arguments they're making around this
topic.
Oh, it is just like they're trying to
say they're like, "Well, he was
perfectly sinless in his divine nature,
but yeah, he took on a sin sinful flesh,
but wasn't a sinner,
right?
Can you explain that any further?"
Well, he was just like we are, but never
sinned. Well, if he was just like we
are, were
sinners sinners, right? Exactly.
Um, yeah. Mind you, this is a general
conference bulletin, guys, and in Ellen
White's lifetime. But carry on. All
right. at Jones again. Then God will so
take us and so use us that our sinful
selves shall not appear to influence or
affect anybody. But God will manifest
his righteous self his glory before men
in spite of all ourselves and our
sinfulness. And that is the mystery of
God in you the hope of glory. God
manifest in sinful flesh. Yikes.
Ellen says this ministry of healing. The
Savior took upon himself the infirmities
of humanity and lived a sinful sinless
life that men might have no fear that
because of the weakness of human nature
they could not overcome. Christ came to
make us partakers of the divine nature
and his life declares that humanity
combined with divinity does not commit
sin.
So SDAs
if you sin you are not combined with
division
like wait a minute Christ is not in you
and you have no hope of glory. Is that
what this is what she's saying
bro? And it's like literally none of
them have arrived at this. This is like
in her in faith and works when she says
uh living faith allied with divinity
will produce perfect obedience to the
ten commandments
but then you ask them are you keeping
the ten commandments perfectly and most
of the ones that are honest are like
well no I'm falling short you know but I
try my best
right
that's not what she's saying and this is
supposed to be precious light from the
throne of God which is again part of the
foundation of this whole
H unbelievable. All right.
Oh my goodness. Perfection. At Jones, I
told you be back. Perfection. Perfection
of character is the Christian goal.
Perfection attained in human flesh in
this world. Could you be any more clear?
Christ attained it. Christ attained it
in human flesh in this world. and thus
made and consecrated a way by which in
him every believer can attain it.
I
I'm moving on. I can't
EJ Wagner again. But before probation
ends, there will be a people so complete
in him that in spite of their sinful
flesh, they will live sinless lives.
They will live sinless lives in mortal
flesh because he who has demonstrated
that he has power over all flesh lives
in them and lived a sinless life in
sinful flesh. Are you hearing what this
man is saying?
And folks, I have yet to see them
denounce any of this.
Oh my goodness.
They will live sinless lives. finally
just
but ultimately it's just like an a bad
christologology
like oh man it's not just a bad like
there's bad anthropology here if you
know their system but like man it's just
a bad christologology it's like
reasoning to make Christ like you are
like well he has to be like I am in and
well right he was fully human
so he was like you in that regard but it
doesn't necessitate to be fully human
that you be a fallen human
oh my gosh
in and sinful flesh. He was born
spiritually alive. He didn't have any
desires to sin. And yes, evil desires
are sinful. Paul says in Colossians,
evil desires even.
Christ didn't have any evil desires
even. He didn't have any want. He was
tempted with things like food in the
wilderness or um you know the the
kingdoms of the world, but he didn't
actually have any evil desire for those
things. Human beings have that evil
desire. and SDA still do if they're
honest and don't think that they're
sinlessly perfect because they're not.
And they still have things that they're
waring with as well, which is why only
Christ is enough.
I'm telling you, this right here, it it
is disgusting. Um, and when you look at
uh 1 John 1, you have to read this. And
uh guys, read 1 John 1. Um, you can read
the whole thing, but 1 John 1 chapter 8
verse 10. We're going to read that right
through now. Um, if we say we have no
sin, we're deceiving ourselves and the
truth is not in us.
I I can't make it any more clear than
that. You know,
verse 9, if we confess our sins, he's
faithful and righteous to forgive us our
sins and cleanse us from all
unrighteousness. If we say we don't have
any sin, we make him a liar and his word
is not in us. Okay?
Written to believers. And this is th
this is this the book. Okay. And then
you have Wagner Jones White, all these
other people trying to tell you that
yeah, sinless lives in mortal flesh.
Really?
Who's telling the truth? That's the
question you got to ask yourselves here.
All right, moving on. LG White's
convoluted ideas of Christ human nature.
Again, let's check this out. So, this
going to be a contradiction or you can
tell me it's not and let's see what you
think. All right. One. Uh, what a sight
this was for heaven to look upon Christ
who knew not the least moral taint of
defile or defilement of sin. Took our
nature in its deteriorated condition.
Okay. Christ took our nature in its
deteriorated condition. Okay. This is
from manuscript releases volume 15 etc
etc. Okay.
Um, we got here, uh, he felt the
disgrace of sin, another quote, as much
more keenly than it is possible for man
to feel it, as his divine and sinless
nature was exalted above the nature of
man. Well, which is it?
Which is it?
Okay. Either he had a sinless pa nature
divine and sinless exalted above the
nature of man or
it is taking on the nature of man in its
following condition.
You you tell me if that's not a
contradiction. What is it? Seven pillars
of the SDA faith. This is number seven.
For the um righteousness by faith, for
the ability to keep the law like Jesus
did, guys. And thanks for hanging in
there with us. I know it's a long one.
Um, but yeah, this is wild, man. Um,
Ellen again, manuscript releases, uh,
volume two. All right. Um, I would that
we had the baptism of the Holy Spirit,
and this we must have before we can
reveal perfection of life and character.
I would that each member of the church
would open the heart to Jesus, saying,
"Come, heavenly guest, abide with me."
All right, good. Nothing wrong with
that, right? Um, let's see. This says uh
this is from um Dennis Smith. I just
found this book uh recently um and read
it. It's it's a devotional book. Um I
just kind of read through it and I was a
little bit perturbed by what I saw. Uh
it's called Spirit Baptism of the 188
and the 1888 message by of righteousness
by faith. Um it's a free download. Um
you can find it if you want to look for
it there. Okay.
um it says because of Jesus's perfect
and righteous obedience to God's law,
when we have Jesus living in us, we have
his righteous obedience available to us.
Therefore, Paul stated that the
righteousness of the law might be
fulfilled in us. Romans 8:4. You see,
because of the weakness of our flesh, we
were unable to fulfill the righteous
requirements of the law. However, if we
have Jesus living in us through the
baptism of the Holy Spirit, he will live
out his righteous obedience in us if we
place our faith quote unquote in him to
do so. This is how we have Christ's
righteousness manifested in our lives.
How we have his righteousness imparted
to us. Okay.
Like ahead.
It's like a a of almost like a form of
like magic. It's viewed like you're
going to get a superpower if you really
believe it'll like enable you now to do
something you couldn't previously do.
And there's some degree to that that's
true that when you're raised to
spiritual newness of life, you now have
new desires. But Paul talks about the
war between the flesh and and the
spirit, the old man and the new man
taking place
your whole life
because there's a part of you that has
yet to be glorified. They try and
shortcircuit this. You should have SDAs
every day who are finally arriving. Like
today, there should have been some SDA
probably around the world somewhere that
30 years ago they were trying and they
finally committed and and now they've
arrived and today was the day they
finally arrived where they're completely
sinless now and they should be
glorified.
Yep. Right. Walk right in the kingdom
like Enoch, right?
Yes. They should because that would be
what being in a glorified state is.
That's the part of the resurrection of
the body because there's an actual
component to your flesh that is fallen.
Yeah.
Christ did not have that.
Yeah, man. All right. Another page 75,
same book. Um, you can see why um you
can see why Satan wants to blind God's
people to the marvelous experience of
the righteousness by faith in Christ
alone. First, he wants to replace Christ
from that aspect of the Christian's
life. Second, he doesn't want us to have
victory over temptation and sin. He does
not want God's law to be obeyed.
For through experiencing the
righteousness by faith, we place Christ
at the very center of our walk with God
and our lives will be a life of
obedience to God. Through our faith in
Christ, obedience to God's law will be
manifested in and through us by Christ.
And that is true righteousness by faith.
Interesting.
Um and again you're seeing the
distinction between um the law and of
course when he's talking about that
they're really talking about the ten
commandments as we talked about earlier.
Okay.
Um let's move on. Um
the Bible, Ellen White, Jones, and
Wagner all agree that the complete
victory over temptation and sin is
possible even now. Funny enough, people
will tell you that they don't believe in
sinless perfection. And this man, Dennis
Smith, explains uh explains that they
do. And we have read it also. Uh the
message of righteousness by faith
presented in 1888 teaches us how we can
have this complete victory through
Christ living in us through the spirit.
Now, um for those who don't know, the
1888 message um is being uh blown up
now. It's being brought to the
forefront. this is where we need to go
back to um you know we need to embrace
this righteousness by faith and again
it's in order to keep the law you're
seeing this from uh from their own
mouths here okay complete victory is the
experience we must all have if we are
living when Jesus comes complete victory
meaning you need to know uh that you're
keeping every law that you don't sin and
that is the experience he says we must
all have if we are living when Jesus
comes no sin right so when probation is
closed you can stand before God without
a mediator according to Ellen White okay
this is why Satan has fought so fiercely
to keep God's people from understanding
the message of righteousness by faith we
need not fear Satan's plots against us
Jesus gained complete victory over our
foe and offers that victory to us
through our faith in his righteousness
Jesus began the work of salvation in our
life and he will bring us to complete
victory as we place our faith in him and
his righteousness. And again I I would
ask the question guys um how many people
um can say that they are without sin?
How many people know one person that is
living this life right now without sin?
Anybody
feel free to tell me. Okay. Um, and if
we're in a situation where we're not
living without sin, if you're in a
situation where you don't know anybody
who's living without sin, where are they
getting this information from?
Right? Said in the scripture, I see that
all have sinned and fall short of the
God's glorious standard. I see that all
over the place, right? Born in sin,
shaped iniquity, all that stuff there,
right? From my mother's womb, right? Um,
and I know me, I have sinned in my life
at least once, right? Um, most of us on
here, all of us on here have sinned at
least once. So, we're not qualified in
that sense, right? Um, but now, as
you're walking with God and and SDAs,
please, if you're listening, I'm
challenging you right now. If you're
listening and you are living without sin
currently, put a one in the chat. We'll
wait. I know we're a couple ahead. uh
seconds ahead of you guys. Um but if
you're living without sin right now,
please put a one in the chat. Okay, as
we're waiting for the ones to come
pouring in here, um we'll go to the next
couple quotes here.
Um yeah. All right, there's more. The
great controversy in semi-aranism. So,
we're almost we're coming to the end,
guys. Um this is kind of where we're at.
Uh, the organization quote unquote
spiritual gifts here. While the
organization espouses a form of
trinitarianism. Oh, that's not the whole
quote. Sorry. Um, this is mine. While
the organization espouses a form of
trinitarianism in their official beliefs
like Heaven Trio, many early SDA
pioneers were Aryans and semi-arans.
Okay. They did not hold an orthodox
trinitarian view of the godhead. All
right. Um this is seen today in a
growing anti-trinitarian movement within
their movement. Um they base their uh
position on the writings of some of the
SCA pioneers including some of EGW's
earliest writings including spiritual
guests volume one. Okay. Um this is
James Springer White Mr. White himself.
All right. To assert that the sayings of
the son and his apostles are the
commandments of the father is as wide
from the truth as the old trinitarian
absurdity that Jesus Christ is the very
and eternal God.
And as the faith of Jesus embraces uh
every requirement peculiar to the
gospel, it is necessarily follow it
necessarily follows pardon me that the
commandments of God mentioned by the
third angel embrace only
only the 10 precepts of the father's
immut immutable law which are not
particular to any one dispensation but
common to all.
This is what it says.
Unbelievable.
I one thing on that real quick and I
promise I'm not going to go super long.
I know I've talked a lot.
He is full of it.
Yeah,
he's full of it. Not only that first
part that's highlighted, but there you
see. No, this guy was an anti-rinitarian
heretic coming from a a a Unitarian
Restorationist movement. Never that I've
seen has repudiated such statements. Nor
has the SDA church. They've tried to
just wax over it, not really say
anything. And oh, well, we just won't
really talk about that publicly. Yeah,
because it's going to cause all sorts of
problems. But that second part, no sir,
you're wrong. Because the the law, the
10 precepts, the 10 words were given by
Yahweh.
Were they not?
Y
were they given by Yahweh CMBB?
Yes, absolutely.
Okay. Jude 5 says that Jesus led the
people of Israel out of bondage and
slavery in Egypt.
Well, what is Deuteronomy 5 link the
fourth commandment to? Your golden calf
commandment. What does it link it to?
Yahweh bringing people out of slavery.
So yes, sir, Jesus is the one true God.
You don't actually understand
trinitarianism. And sadly, you've now
passed off this damnable heresy to other
people who now believe this damnable
heresy because of this guy.
Sorry, this works me up so bad with this
movement because this is why this is a
heresy. This is still a part of the
movement today such that they allow for
people who hold stuff like this because
deep down the high echelons know about
these sorts of quotes,
right? You know, and um again, this is
it's there, right? And shout out to
Thunder, you know, hidden in plain
sight, right? So, unless you're reading
this stuff, you won't even know that
this is influencing some of this uh some
of your thoughts. Okay? Some people have
a have a a weird hierarchy, you know.
Um, what's up, Derek? Um, some people
have a weird hierarchy of um uh of of
the trinitarian uh God. And sometimes
they'll say, well, it's not trinitarian.
It's, you know, Jesus was a really good
guy and they have adoptionism, they have
the the Aryanism, they have the
semi-aranism. All kind of nonsense going
on. and they can't make sense of it
because uh they can't they're seeing the
scriptures through the lens of what
James White says through what Ellen says
through uh you know uh everyone else
says and in the early earliest writings
here you know before she openly embraced
um or tried to embrace uh trinitarianism
but the cat was already out of the bag
uh the horse was out of the stall
whatever you want to talk call it you
couldn't unring the bell and it's a
whole convoluted mess and none of it can
be repudiated because all of it was
given under inspiration. Okay, quote
unquote, let's move on, y'all. James
White again, um he says, "The
exhortation to contend for the faith
delivered to the saints is to us alone
really." And it is very important for us
to know uh what for and how to contend.
In the fourth verse, that's Jude 4, he
gives us the re the reason why we should
contend for the faith, a particular
faith. quote for though there are
certain men or a certain class who deny
the only Lord God and our Lord Jesus
Christ. The way spiritualizers have
disposed of or denied the only Lord God
and our Lord Jesus Christ is by first
using the old and his words unscriptural
trinitarian creed that Jesus Christ is
the eternal God. Though they have not
one passage to support it. while we have
plain scripture testimony in abundance
that he is the son of the eternal God.
This is James White and the day star.
And again, we can go over and over and
over throughout scripture and find uh um
the principles that that that helped us
come to the arrival of the doctrine of
the trinity. Okay. Yes, you're not going
to see the word trinity in scripture.
You're also not going to see the word
Bible in scripture. That's okay, right?
You know, but the the the concept of the
trinity is like when we're gathering all
the things that God said about himself,
right? What Christ has said and what the
spirit has said,
what God has revealed.
Exactly. Right. And we're looking at
this from an overall standpoint, which
was the meta narrative that was spoken
of earlier. You have no choice but to
arrive at the the concept of the the
trinity. Okay. Um yes, there was some uh
some nuance to it. Yes, the words were
uh you know uh brought uh out out
earlier or later, I should say. Um, you
heard the term hypoatic union. Um, we
can do a show on that some other time in
the future. Um, I actually have uh I've
been having this show in the can for
probably three years now. Um, it's
called uh who is God? I was supposed to
do a series on that um as well. And
we're looking at the trinitarian nature
of God. That'll be coming up on my
channel at some point in time. Um, I'll
release it when the time is right. Um
but you know we're looking at the nature
of God and looking at the attributes of
God and uh this the father son and the
spirit have these attributes and that's
why we we're arrived at the the the
concept of the trinity. They are
distinct yet they are all god
right
and there's one god that
there's the doctrine of the trinity and
there's the biblical evidence for the
trinity. They're not the same thing. You
mentioned the language being a
development. Right. That's the doctrine
of the trinity.
Correct. Yeah. That's not the biblical
evidence for the trinity, which is what
the doctrine is based on. And it's
seeking to use language that helps to s
or or accurately and succinctly
communicate what is found in the Bible.
Correct?
And when you look at all of scripture,
there is no way to understand the God of
scripture outside of the Trinity.
And if you don't understand that,
you more than likely have a wrong
understanding of what the Trinitarian
God is.
Um, oh, I'm sorry. Go ahead. I didn't
mean to cut you off.
No, no, I was just going to say that
that's it. Like that you you more than
likely don't fundamentally understand
who the trinitarian God is. And it's not
to say that you can wrap your mind
around it necessarily. Um but God's not
made in my image. God's not made in in
the image of creation, but we have
language that can be used to accurately
describe what scripture in tot.
Correct. Yeah. Um and I've heard I think
it's Frank Turk that mentioned it like
this. Um it says that you can't it's not
that God can't be uh can't be um
apprehended. You know God can can't be
comprehended like the fullness of God.
We're not we're finite. We're not going
to comp comprehend the whole and
fullness of God. But we can apprehend
it, right? We can grasp hold of it, you
know, and see what the scriptur is
telling us, what God has revealed from
us, right? And we can meditate on these
things and understand them, right? So,
not only just from a scriptural
standpoint, but you know, if we're using
our our intellect, we are commanded to
love the Lord our God with all our
heart, soul, and mind, right? Um we're
we can we can do this, right? Um and so
it's not like you can't it can't be
understood. It can be. Um so with that
said, um oh, the last thing I was going
to say about that was the creeds, right?
Um the SDA church, uh it's almost like
you try to draw um Christianity from
memory,
right? uh the the pioneers were um and
they got rid of all the creeds and so
forth like that. And mind you, we do not
base doctrine on creeds. Okay?
No.
Creeds have come about as a result of
what the scripture teaches. And again,
what Miles said is a matter of just kind
of putting a button on it, putting a
nice bow, it's able to be communicated
and brought to other people fairly
easily. And then, well, how did you come
by these things? Hey, let's go in the
text and we can see where it comes from,
right? Um, and that's one of those
things that with the SDA pioneers, um,
none of them were wellversed in
scriptures. None of them were were uh,
theologians. None of them were good at
any of this stuff, right? And they tried
to do
they weren't even versed in the creeds
that they hated,
right?
I've shown them before on this channel
and we'll continue to do it further
because multiple of the pioneers were
this way. They didn't even understand,
for example, what the creeds are saying
when they say that God is not made up of
parts,
right?
They took that to mean
uh
essentially what what the creed is
actually saying is that God does not
have like two ears and eyes because God
is spirit. He can't be pieced apart and
like broken up into pieces like a
physical creature can. That's what was
being said there because there's context
around why something like that needed to
be said at that time due to certain
heresies that were out there. But
nevertheless, the SDAs, the pioneers, if
you read them on these sorts of things,
they don't even understand what's being
said. They think something's being said
that wasn't even being said by the
creed.
So, they didn't even know what the
creeds were that they were criticizing,
right? Um, and you know, I think we
talked about it before. Um, and you
know, do your research, guys. Um, look
and see how old um, we all know that
Ellen White was like 17 or something
like that of The Great Disappointment,
right? 16, 17, something like that. Um,
James White was barely older than she
was. Okay. Like five years.
I think he was 24
something like that, right? Um so you
know I guess seven years maybe. Yeah. Um
so he was there recent convert
relatively recent convert. He was uh I
think he wasn't converted till he was
like uh into Christian faith at all
until like age 17 or 20 or something
like that or or 18 something like that.
And then after that he left the
Christian faith and and joined the
Christian connection which is a
heretical group. Okay. So, you have a
baby Christian running around here
trying to say he's going to start a new
uh concept uh and we're we're going to
reinvent the wheel here, right?
And you end up following Miller. Really?
And bringing your false god with you
because Miller didn't agree with James
White's understanding of who God is,
man. Bro, it's it's unbelievable, man.
And the these these are the the flagship
uh SDAs, by the way, right? These these
are the pillars, right? Good grief. All
right. Come on. Jan Andrews, top
theologian. Here we go. The um the
doctrine of the trinity which was
established by the church by the council
of Nika. Wrong. Uh
this doctrine destroys the personality
of God and his son Jesus Christ our
Lord. The infamous measures by which it
was forced upon the church will appear
upon the stages of ecclesiastical
history might well cause every believer
in that doctrine to blush. This is the
the same Andrews through whom the
Andrews Seminary is named after.
University of Andrews, my alma mater.
Okay. Andrews University, excuse me.
Right. Uh this is one of the things that
you need to recognize. This guy does not
know what the heck he's talking about.
Right. I have no choice words, but this
is a Christian show, a family show.
We're going to leave it as is for now.
Right.
It shows he doesn't even understand the
Trinity.
What do you mean? It destroys the
personality of God and his son Christ
our Lord. Sir, did you even bother to
read the Aanian creed?
Unbelievable.
What do you mean? What do you mean? He's
exclusively referred to as the son
in the whole creed. That's his that's
his exclusive title in St. Aanius the
Great, the great defender of the
Trinity. It's like the most
What do you mean? It just That's what
I'm saying. when they say stuff like
this and the SDA church just tries to
wax over it and act like, "Oh, well,
like you me and said, one of the
greatest uh theologians of the SDA
church ever has been uh the Jane
Andrews. He mentioned that at the annual
council."
Yeah.
Well, this guy was an anti-trinitarian
heretic. And you're here warning people
about anti-trinitarian heretics that are
pointing to this guy for their support,
right?
Yeah. This just clueless blind leading
the blind. All right, moving on. Got to
hurry, guys. Um, and as to the son of
God, he would be excluded also, for he
had god for his father and did some
point in the eternity of the past have
beginning of days. Are you hearing this?
Are y'all Are y'all really hearing this?
So that if we use Paul's language in an
absolute sense, it would be impossible
to find but one being in the universe
and that is God the father who is
without father or mother or descent or
beginning of days or end of life.
Unbelievable.
Moving on. All right. EJ Wagner again.
While both are of the same nature,
the father is first in point of time. He
is also greater in that he had no
beginning. while Christ's personality
had a beginning. End quote. Like this,
if y'all know anything about church
history and about Christologology, this
is not all nonsense and heresy. Carry
on. All right. Jerry Moon, Adventist
theologian and professor. Okay. Um, more
recently, a further question has arisen
with increasing urgency. Was the
pioneers belief about the godhead right
or wrong? As one line of reasoning goes,
either the pioneers were wrong and the
present church is right or the pioneers
were right and the present 7th Day
Adventist Church has apostasized from
biblical truth Jerry Moon, Adventist
theologian and professor. Um you guys
can see the reference there. Um
understanding God's love, the trinity.
Um this is this is oh man this is um
this is a fork in the road.
This is why they don't want to talk
about this topic.
Right.
Right. And mind you uh according to this
book right here. Right. Um the trinity
is uh a fundamental belief. Okay.
Mind you, what it actually teaches in
there of the Trinity isn't what the rest
of the Christian world would call the
Trinity at all. Okay? So, you have to
make the decision on what is actually
being taught here is what this book
says, okay? If this if what this book
says is true, then the rest of the
entire uh Christian uh uh collective,
the entire body of Christ across the
univer the go the globe right now has it
wrong.
It's an eitheror situation, y'all.
There's no room for in between. If you
get that wrong, what else is wrong?
Okay. All right, Jerry Moon.
Okay. Uh great controversy. So, the
beginnings of the great controversy. And
we're wrapping it up, guys, here in the
last couple bits. Um,
all right. Satan, once an honored el uh
angel in heaven next to Christ, his
countenance was like those of the other
angels, was mild and expressive of
happiness. Um, his forehead, and I have
this highlighted on purpose, his
forehead was high and broad, showing
great intelligence. Okay, this is part
and parcel of phronology. Um Ellen White
at one point um affirmed and then
another points denied frenology that is
the head shape um that would be um
characteristic of one's character um
will intellect um you know the ability
to um to reason etc right um and so his
forehead is high and broad showing great
intelligence is a nod to that okay
moving on uh his form was perfect his
bearing noble and majestic but when God
said to his son, "Let us make man in our
image." Satan was jealous of Jesus. He
wished to be consulted concerning the
formation of a man. Right? So again,
guys, and I have to start with the um
the commentary now. Um you know, with
with this said, we have this um this
idea that Satan is an honored angel in
heaven next to Christ. This implies that
Jesus is an angel, right? Or something
like that. Okay. The separation between
God and his son, which is seen all over
the place in spiritual gift volume one.
We see this in story of redemption. Um
we see this in uh I think this early
writings, whatever the case says. Um we
see these um these distinctions where
it's almost like Christ is
not quite God, not quite, you know, uh
the same. He he's closeish, kind of
godlike, but not really. And where we
have this idea of Christ being Michael
the Archangel. If you know anything
about the word Michael, it means one who
is like God. All right? And so this is
one of those things where oh no, no, we
believe in the Trinity, but he's also
Michael the Archangel. One who's like
unto God, right? So, you know, you get
the you get the the double uh speak uh
through there. Um go ahead before I uh
I was just going to say Satan was never
next to Christ.
Right.
there there is no comparison because
again this shows that no they're not
trinitarians and Jerry Moon who was just
on the screen we've looked at his paper
before uh the quest for a biblical
trinity where he talks about well
there's actually two types of trinity
within Ellen White's writings
no there's not and no Satan was never
next to Christ that shows you do not
understand the triune God
right um and then uh and I'll that's a
good segue to this uh the last
highlighted part here But when God said
to his son, "Let us make man in our
image." Uh, Satan was jealous of Jesus.
Now, how could a created being uh be
jealous of an uncreated being?
All right? How can you be jealous like
he wished to be consulted concerning the
formation of man? How in the world would
Satan or Lucifer in this point have the
ability or the knowhow how to create
something else? And this is where the
implication of Jesus being uh or or them
being semi-aran or Aryan altogether
where uh Christ is not uh of the same
substance of the father um or even some
sort of demigod or something like that.
Um they don't articulate it in those
ways. Don't get me wrong, I want I don't
want to create a straw man here. They
don't articulate it in those ways. But
this is what we're seeing here, right?
Okay. And because he was not compre um
finishing the quote here uh consulted
that is uh concerning the formation of
man. He was filled with envy, jealousy
and hatred. He desired to receive the
highest honors in heaven next to God.
Until this time all heaven had been in
order, harmony and perfect subject
subjection to the government of God. And
it was the highest sin to rebel against
his order and will. All heaven seemed in
commotion. Um, the angels were marshaled
in companies, each division with a
higher commanding angel at its head. And
Satan, ambitious to exalt himself and
unwilling to submit to the authority of
Jesus, was insinuating against the
government of God. Here we go. Some of
the pe the angels sympathi sympathized
with Satan in his rebellion, and others
strongly contended for the honor and
wisdom of God in giving authority to his
son. Hm. There was contention among the
angels. Satan and his sympathizers were
striving to reform the government of
God. They wished to look into his
uncarchable wisdom and ascertain his
purposes in exalting Jesus and uh
endowing him with such unlimited power
and command. Um and again guys, look at
what we're we're reading here. This is
something where Jesus uh according to
Satan's um this worldview here anyway um
he shouldn't deserve to have command
over everybody. He shouldn't had deserve
to have authority. Right? Cuz the father
endowed him with such unlimited power.
Right? Meanwhile, um John chapter 1 says
in the beginning was the word. The word
was with God and the word was God. He
was with God in the beginning. All
things were created through him and
apart from him not one thing was created
that has been created. So the question
that you all have to ask yourselves is
does a created being have the ability to
create?
Okay. Does a created being have the
ability to create? And if not then you
have to look at the true nature of the
pre-incarnate word that's before birth.
Who was Jesus?
somebody like God
or in the beginning with God who was God
yet distinct.
Not just that, but Isaiah 44:24 says,
"The Lord Jehovah."
That's the word that's used there.
Yahweh, Jehovah, the Lord alone
created all things.
There you go.
Well, the Jehovah's Witnesses and any of
these semi-aran types can't actually,
this is again why you have to be a
trinitarian if you believe the Bible
because we're told that the spirit
created things. We're told the father
created in Isaiah
later on in Isaiah, I think 56, we're
also then told that Jesus created by
Paul in Colossians 1 and John in chapter
1.
Yet, we're told that there's only one
Jehovah.
Mhm.
Okay. Well, we have to be able to
differentiate and distinguish between
the fact that the one Jehovah has
clearly
revealed himself as father, son, and
spirit.
Mhm.
Boom. There you go. That that's that's
what's going on there. Well, you can't
have that in this. The son was given
authority.
This is why their whole Well, we don't
we use person and being the same way.
Well, you shouldn't,
right? You shouldn't. That this remote
has being, but it doesn't have
personhood. They're not the same thing.
And just because your prophet has made
that blunder doesn't mean the rest of
the Christian world now needs to follow
suit.
Yeah.
Facts. All right. Um, next quote, guys.
Um, they rebelled against the authority
of the son of God, and all the angels
were summoned to appear before the
father to have their cases decided. And
it was decided that Satan should be
expelled from heaven and that the angels
who um excuse me and that the angels all
who joined with Satan in the rebellion
should be turned out with him. Then
there was war in heaven. Angels were
engaged in the battle. Satan wished to
conquer the son of God and those who
were submissive to his will. But the the
good and true angels prevailed and Satan
with his followers were driven from
heaven.
God is the father of Christ. Christ is
the son of God. To Christ has been given
an exalted position and he has been made
equal with the father. All the councils
of God are open to his son. This is what
she says in testimonies. And yeah, go
ahead. I'll set up for you.
Given it, brother.
Given.
Yeah.
Given to Christ has been given. They
like to appeal to patriarchs and
prophets page 37 to say, "No, no, no.
Look, see over here she says that there
was no real change in Christ.
Well, then she clearly shouldn't have
been she was definitely not qualified to
be correcting the church universal
because apparently the woman didn't even
know what the word given meant.
Right?
It happens.
Given means he didn't have it by
definition,
right?
Because this then gives you insight into
how they use the term God, which is also
informed by the great controversy theme.
It's used like a familial title.
It's not a descriptor of the Yes. It's
not a descriptor of the single
substance,
the one being, the one mode of existence
that's co-eternal, co-equal. And he has
expressed himself in three persons. And
by persons we mean the ability to
uh will to self-reflect, to speak, be
spoken to, etc. Yet the three persons
are are one in being in their actual
nature and being. They are completely
equal. Now in the the plan of
redemption, they take different roles.
It's not the father that incarnated.
It's not the spirit that incarnated.
It's the son,
etc. There's different roles in that
regard. But ontologically, meaning in
their being.
Yeah.
All equal. The one God.
Good stuff, brother.
All right. Um, so a couple artwork and
we this is kind of reviewing what we
just uh read here. Um, so this is Satan
being jealous. This is Jesus talking
about, oh, we're going to create human
beings in this planet called Earth that
will create and such like that. And all
the angels are listening and Satan's
upset here. Lucifer, right? Um, so of
course Lucifer has upset, you know. Um,
Miles and I are going back and forth
about this. I never noticed this angel
in the back. Uh, I guess this would be
um on the left side of the screen here.
Um, this angel in the back like in the
presence of I guess that's God back
there, the Father. Um, I didn't know if
that was supposed to be Jesus or not
because I didn't notice these other
couple angels behind here. Maybe they're
all waiting to get their assignments or
something like that. I don't know. Um,
but it's kind of interesting to see that
um thing. Um, and then of course on the
right here, uh, Satan in the middle,
Lucifer, uh, trying to convince other
people, gee, the father's wrong, and
blah blah blah, you know. Um, so this is
this is uh, uh, the artwork that depict
depicts what they believe um, in the
great controversy theme. I think the one
on the right is actually Lucifer is
supposed to be the blondhaired one and
it's the scene from Patriarchs and
Prophets where the angel God's angels
are like, "No, no, no, you can trust
him."
Oh, God. He's got his arms crossed.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. and and he's standing there and
then this is after he has already
consulted an interview with Jesus by an
angel that was passing by
to then gave his false repentance
where he supposedly repented but it
Christ's heart was broken. He was
weeping over it because it was he knew
it wasn't real repentance
and he said that if he could be admitted
back into heaven that things just
wouldn't work out and so basically he
could never be forgiven and he goes into
like fullon rage mode. Um, maybe I'm
crossing a couple wires there, but if I
recall, it's been a minute since I've
gone through that specific whole
narrative, but I'm pretty sure that's
what that piece is is coming from.
Okay, I'm going to have to review that
again because I I'd plan to read some uh
tonight, but I knew these were going to
be a super long uh stream tonight, but
yikes. All right. And of course, hey,
you know, you like it now. He's got dark
hair, so he's the bad guy now.
You know what I'm saying? Come join me.
You know, and then here we go. there's
war in heaven um and so forth and he's
cast down. Um yeah, so here's the the
recap, guys. So you can screenshot that
for later. All right. Um but you can see
all that there. Okay. Yeah. So um the
Mormon plan of salvation and the SCA uh
great controversy similarities, right?
I just thought this was interesting to
bring up. Sorry. I'll let you take over.
That's fine. Yeah.
No, you're good. Um, I just added this
because I think it's important for
people to realize the crossovers and
we're going to save that obviously for a
different night. I'm gonna end up doing
a stream specifically on this topic, but
um, there's a paper that somebody sent
me, a partner of ours, and I was super
grateful for it because I'm like, dude,
I probably would have never found this.
And it was an article from a B the BYU
archives, which is the Mormon
University. Really? um the the
equivalent of the equivalent of like the
the uh yeah like the SDA archives, you
know,
and it was talking about the
similarities between Ellen White and
Joseph Smith's first vision. Now, the
agenda of the Mormon guy in his paper,
it was interesting because he had a
different agenda than the SDAs obviously
would. And it was dealing with the how
do we deal with the fact that there were
two prophets at the same time period who
had very similar first visions and were
making very similar claims. How do we
know we're the Latter-day Saints and
it's not them?
That was kind of the standpoint it was
coming from. But nevertheless, he talks
about in the paper how and we're going
to do, like I said, a stream on this
folks where he talks about in this paper
that the first visions have tons of
similarities. And he said it's something
that's virtually undisussed in history
that this first vision of both of them
is so very similar. Well, the first
vision in Ellen White's case, it's a
little different in Joseph Smith's case,
but in Ellen's case, it contains a lot
of these details. Now, it ended up
taking up to the great controversy
vision at the funeral where um really
the details were coming through, which
um I've got my own theories on that. But
all that to say, you can see here folks,
you can screenshot this if you want. And
I'm sure there's more than this. These
are just nine that I'm aware of that are
similarities across the board between
both of these um plans of salvation.
Essentially, it's provided by the
prophet, not found in the Bible. There
was a heavenly council held to figure
out the plan. Uh the council was based
on eternal laws. Uh both Jesus and
Lucifer presented plans.
Lucifer was barred from council
participation.
Jesus is Michael the Archangel in both
of them. Now they don't necessarily mean
the same thing on all of these, but the
the claims are essentially the same, but
what they mean are different.
This plan was in effect in other worlds.
So you mentioned the heavenly
intelligences earlier and how Jesus was
in that art over there, you know, the
we're going to create the earth, etc.
There's all these other worlds already
out there
that were already created with all this
other intelligence on it. Jesus's plan
was accepted because it was in
accordance with those laws.
And then Lucifer rebels and begins
attacking God's plan and law, which is
essentially again what is going on in
the great controversy. Ultimately,
Satan's mad that Jesus was given
something he didn't have. He rebelss,
begins attacking God's law, wants to set
up his own form of church governance.
And then both of these stories from
Mormons and uh SDAs are both essentially
coming from influenced by John Milton's
Paradise Lost.
Yes. Yes. Um and that that uh is
something that people need to recognize,
you know, um that uh
the influences are kind of on top of one
another. Um Ellen White's cousin, um I
think it was her second cousin or
something like that, uh end up being
Joseph Smith's, uh one of his one of his
wives, you know. Um it's it's a very
it's a very small leap. Um I like to
call u Mormons and SDA's kissing
cousins. You know, JW's the same uh same
way. You know, um they are all uh
stemming from some of the similar uh
situations from the Millerite movement
and so forth like that. Um uh First
Nephi chapter 8 um is the narrow path
vision that Ellen White talks about. Um
that in the Book of Mormons, First Nephi
chapter 8, you can find it there. Um,
and it's it's ripped off,
you know, and so we have to be able to
recognize these things. And unless
you're wanting to call Joseph Smith the
true prophet that Ellen White borrowed
from or that God gave Joseph Smith that
vision and Ellen White got it from him
as one of the gems that was scattered in
all these places, these rough places or
whatever she said, you know, then you
really have to pay uh, you know, you
have to really choose what you're
actually doing here. you know what what
are you believing and why? Um and some
of it's just bad. Okay. Uh so then again
the great controversy here of course
Christ is tempting s or Satan is
tempting Christ uh in the wilderness
here and you know he can fight him off
by saying it is written and so can you
you know you can stand in your own faith
right there. Um and of course we're all
chess pieces on the board here. Um you
know in the great controversy theme. So
all of the unfollowing worlds are
watching everything play out and Christ
and uh Satan are are playing using us as
pawns and their their their plans or
whatever the case is. And um eventually
we'll be uh able to stand before God
without a mediator and so forth. Okay.
Um couple of last couple things here. Um
the inhabitants of unfollowing worlds.
This commentary volume six. As you can
see, the inhabitants of unfollowing
worlds and the heavenly universe are
watching with an intense interest the
conflict between good and evil. They
rejoice as Satan's subtleties one after
another are discerned and met with. It
is written as Christ met with them in
his conflict with the wily foe. Every
victory gained is a gem in the crown of
life. In the day of victory, all the
universe of heaven triumphs. The harps
of the angels send forth forth the most
pre precious music accompanying the
melody of the voice. Again, I've always
had this question and I've never heard a
good answer for it. Uh maybe I can help
me in the chat. Um the the inhabitants
of unfallen worlds and of the heavenly
universe are watching with an intense
interest in the conflict between good
and evil. How are they seeing this uh
take place? you know, are are there big
giant screens on like in in the sky on
their planets? Like like and I'm not
being facitious. I'm really asking I
don't know, right? If this is accurate,
how are they seeing this? Are they
seeing this in their mind's eye? Is this
being uh taught on Sabbaths?
Not just that, but but they need to say
that they need to say that these he
these intelligences are in other
universes cuz
if it's like it was depicted in that art
where it's like, oh, we're going to
create Earth, but all of the other
cosmos already exists.
Well, they're watching good and evil.
Well, how hasn't evil tainted where
they're at,
right?
It's the whole cosmos that he's
redeeming, right? All of the creation.
Well, no. We're the only ones that ate
the fruit, Miles. Of course. Yeah, as
all of them have a tree of good and evil
on their planet, right?
So, I guess if you leave Earth, then if
you were to go to outer space, there's
not sin there.
Sin hasn't touched that part of of
creation. Then,
how are these intelligent lives that
haven't experienced the fallenness of
the creation? They'd have to be in some
other universe to where it's like, well,
it's only this universe. And then you
get into all sorts of interesting
questions that again, none of this is in
scripture. This is coming from the great
controversy theme. Yet this is their SDA
Bible commentary.
Yeah.
Where are you commenting at on the Bible
that this is what's going on.
Imagine
boy. All right. God has worlds upon
worlds which are that are obedient to
his law. These worlds are con uh
conducted with reference to the glory of
the creator. As the inhabitants of these
worlds see the great price that has been
paid to ransom man, they are filled with
amazement. With intense interest, they
watch the the controversy between Christ
and Satan. And as this controversy
progresses and the glory of God shines
brighter and brighter, they give praise
to God again. How are they seeing this?
And if these unfallen worlds, that's
right, Amazonware. If these unfollow
worlds are obedient to his laws, then
you have to recognize something. And
this is something I brought up in
Sabbath show I did with the BK Apologist
and um Servant of Christ Ministries a
couple years back. Um you can find it on
my channel on my playlist.
Um
the if we're gonna keep the Sabbath at
the same time as planet Earth because
we're all on the same seven uh six day
creation schedule, right? allegedly.
Then um if we're going to be keeping the
same hours of the Sabbath,
then physically speaking, those planets
either have to be the exact same size of
the Earth,
be the exact same distance from their
sun as we are from our sun. and their
planets have to spin on their axis at
the same exact speed that Earth spins on
its axis for all heaven to be keeping
the Sabbath at the same time. Okay? Now,
we can look at that and notice that
that's not even the case in our own
solar system because Saturn, for
example, has a 10-hour day. We have a
24ish
hour day. Okay? So the world spins once
around on its axis. Um 20 it takes about
24 hours to do that for the sun to be in
the same spot. Uh again, right? Um give
or take. Um we can't even do that here.
So if we're really going to get into uh
the nitty-gritty of these things, then
you have to recognize where the problems
lie um by holding on to this type of
tradition. Okay. Um, again, I have no
problem if you want to rest on Sabbath.
Go ahead and rest, right? You you can
you can do that. Nobody's I I don't
particularly care if you do or you
don't. Okay? I won't be hunting you down
um when whenever these Phantom Sunday
laws are passed. Um I'm going to be mad
because there's no more football on TV.
That's what I'm going to be doing. But,
you know, um that's beside the point.
You know, what we're trying to say is
that uh none of this stuff is making a
lot of logical sense. All right? Um from
that aspect. So, keep on rolling. Okay.
Um,
and yet because finite men can discern a
little of God's marvelous power, they
take the glory that belongs to the
creator. Oh, that the veil could be
removed and they could see beyond their
wisdom. Every mouth would cease its
boasting. Men would see the greatness of
the plans of God, and their knowledge
would seem to them unspeakably inferior.
They would never again think themselves
qualified to sit in judgment on God's
plans or to arraign him before the
tribunal that they might pass sentence
on his works. This is Ellen White
talking in the Review and Herald in
1900. Now wait a minute. She is saying
that they would never again think
themselves qualified to sit in judgment
on God's plan. Isn't it the whole point
of the great controversy
where God is sitting
um in uh and his character is being
maligned by Satan
and the whole point of those who are
redeemed during the millennial reign
will be to look at the books and to
judge God as accurate his just and true
are all your ways. You did it right God.
Yep, that's true. Those people should
have been lost. Yep, you're right. These
guys were able to live a sinless life
before probation closed um and stand
before you without a mediator. You did
it right. The whole point is for them to
be sitting in the judgment seat of God.
And now Ellen White is saying that these
people, this should never be so. Like
what gives?
Like make up your mind, please. and then
let us know what you're what you're
actually coming with so we can see if
it's biblical or not because this
clearly is not. Right? Um
they would never think themselves
qualified to sit in judgment. And that's
what you're going to you're telling the
world that you're going to be doing
during the thousand-year millennial
reign of Christ. Unbelievable.
Okay. Again, um this is the triumph of
God's love. Um I have that uh that's the
very cover that I have in this old book
here. um one of the screen pops up show
you that hard copy I have here right uh
the story of the vindication of God's
character this is old school right here
so um this is the great controversy um
in picture book form actually guys uh so
you can see some old pictures there or
whatever um so some artwork and the
screens and so forth like that um but
yeah uh this uh is one of those things
that you know guys um it's to vindicate
the character of God that's the whole
point And Garrick, the thing of it is
for me, um, if God who says who he says
he is in the scriptures, um, if he is
the highest, the greatest possible
being, as they say in, um, in Christian
philosophy,
um, there is no shadow of turning as it
says in the book of James, right? He is
good. He is love, he is all things that
are right. evil is a a privation or
deprivation of good, a deprivation of
having God's character, right? Um then
how in the world are we sitting in
judgment of him?
Why would you doubt him is my question.
How is it that your uh your um your
entire esqueological framework is based
on the fact that the people that are
surrounding him in heaven now can't
trust him and they're waiting for us to
show it. He can be trusted.
Unbelievable.
The story of the vindication of the
character of God and the salvation of
mankind. And again you can see that but
underneath the arrow this book is also
published under the title the great
controversy between Christ and Satan. So
yeah this is
guys oh man this is too much. The whole
point of the great controversy again is
to for the creature can judge the
creator and deem him trustworthy. We
cannot expect to judge God and not judge
God at the same time. Right? Got to make
sense for it guys. Um and that's it.
Okay. Um, thanks for hanging out with
us, man. Um, I'm gonna stop uh
presenting my screen here. Uh, yeah. And
so, yeah, I um I implore you, right? Um,
you've been hanging with us for almost
four hours here. Miles, man, I got to
stop hanging out with you.
I love everything.
We do long streams here.
Yeah, I love every time stamps.
Facts.
People can come back,
consume it all. But it it takes
something like this to do what we're
doing.
Yeah, it does. It's not just like, oh,
we can cover this in an hour.
Yeah. No, no, it's too convoluted, you
know. Um, and at the end of the day, um,
you know, what can you say? You saw
those all those inter uh this mutually
supported cluster. You know what a
cluster is, but it's a mutually
supported cluster.
These pillars that have to lean on each
other. Okay. All of that is based on
justification of what did not happen on
18 uh October 22nd, 1844.
Nothing happened. And they tried to say,
well, something had to happen.
Okay. How could how could we be wrong
about this? Father Miller was right.
Ellen White says, I saw that the 1843
chart the 1843 chart uh should be should
not be altered. the 1843 chart and God's
hand was over and hit a mistake in the
figure
that was altered three times,
right? You know, um, unbelievable. Like,
I mean, when it boils down to it, this
is what they're justifying. And then, of
course, hiring Edson, they're weeping.
They're crying heads Edson um and oral
Croer in the cornfield. Um, and they're
trying to figure out what the heck
happened rather than admitting, you know
what, no man does know the day or the
hour and we were wrong about that. Lord
forgive us for our error. and just chalk
it up and call it a day. Go back to
church. Be humble. You know,
they had too much invested. Too much
invested. And in that day and age, it
wasn't like today, you know.
It's like when you're invested like they
were,
um, it's understandable in in that
context, but at the same time, it
doesn't make it correct.
There's been lots of people that have
genuinely believed all sorts of stuff.
The Jehovah's Witnesses truly believe
Jesus came back in the early 1900s to
Earth.
Yeah.
So do Mormons.
Invisible return of grace. Yeah. that
doesn't that doesn't make it true.
So, I understand that they may have had
valid reasons or whatever, but at the
end of the day, truth is what matters.
Truth is what matters, folks. CMBB,
thank you for being here. Anything you
want to share before you go and then I
will get us closed out, but the floor
will be yours just to share any last
thoughts that you have.
Okay. Uh thanks again, uh Miles, for
having me, bro. Uh it's always great
hanging with you, brother. Um and so
again, I want to just um extend my thank
you uh to you. Uh and um my apologies
for last week. you're supposed to be on
last week and I had some unforeseen
circumstances happen uh around the house
so I had to take care of that right
away. Um so my apologies for that and
you know I again I thank you for being
you um and doing what you do. Uh the
whole team at answering adventism uh.com
you know um and the whole team that are
on Instagram and every place else at
answering an adventism is God bless you
all. You're doing uh what I believe is
the work of the Lord. Um with that said
um man you see it guys. Um, this is the
worldview uh that makes uh SDASism. All
right, the the the world view tick. It's
what makes it work.
And it's based on vision.
It's based on egregious biblical error.
It's based on works of the flesh.
All right? And I don't mean like
fornication and you know uh that kind of
thing. Um but it is works of the flesh.
I have to eat a certain way so I can
understand biblical truth. Scripture
doesn't say that, right? I have to buy
into Ellen White as a prophet is.
Scripture doesn't say that. I don't care
what you think Romans 19 or Revelation
19 says 9 and 10. It's not talking about
her. Okay. Um it it's it's based on this
idea that you can live sinlessly perfect
in this life, right? And again, oh, it's
cuz well well God gives us the ability
to do it, right? And Christ in us. Well,
that's not what it's saying, right?
They're trying to tell you that, but
they're selling you something that's not
achievable. And many of you, if you were
like me and you took it seriously, um it
is crazym
because you know in your heart of hearts
that you're in a you're you sin and you
are in need of a savior and to try and
go over and over losing sleep and what
else can I not do to make God happy? God
already loves you. This is why scripture
says, "For God so loved the world that
he gave his only son that whoever
believes in him should not perish but
have everlasting life." Right? This is
why he says that um the love of God is
what holds us together. He constrains
us. Right? Um in that he says in that
while we were yet sinners,
Christ died for us. This is how God
commends his love towards us. shows us
that before we came to him, he came to
us.
And that's the gospel in a nutshell. We
can go on into the details and the
nitty-gritty and all the rest of it uh
at another time, but at the end of the
day, we were in rebellion
and our savior came to rescue us
and he succeeded.
He succeeded. And not only did he rescue
us, he reigns today,
right now. And he's calling us to
represent him, not by your works,
but by your love for for God and your
love for your fellow man.
This happens by giving us the gift of
his spirit, which is the seal, not the
Sabbath.
And so, the spirit of God lives on us on
the inside of us and calls us to
repentance day by day. This the spirit
that convicts us of sin,
right? And so as he convicts us and and
creates us and conforms us into the
image of Christ day by day, um we become
become more like him, right? And our job
is to just hey, let me tell you about
this man, Jesus. Let me tell you about
the gospel. Let me tell you about what
happened, you know, and we're supposed
to represent him in the earth.
I saw that say this guys that um you can
hold on to um works if you want to and
know that you're falling short or you
can cling to Christ and recognize I I
can't do it on my own. I've never been
able to do it on my own and I need a
savior and I have one. Um, that said,
guys, um, I want to just go ahead and
shut it down. Uh, for those that are
Christians and need to, um, uh, had no
friends, family, co-workers, whatever,
um, that are SDAs. Um, now I hope that
this stream has helped you to understand
the mindset and you now know how to
start to uh to where to where to begin,
you know, um when to when when uh
witnessing or just talking with SDAs and
kind of getting down to the uh brass tax
of what's being said when they're saying
certain things so that you can give them
the gospel. All right. Um, many of us
that are out, we're at peace with the
Savior because we know we're rescued and
it had nothing to do with us. You know,
that said, I love y'all. Um, love y'all
with the love of Christ, even if I
disagree with you. And again, Brother
Miles, thank you. I appreciate you, bro.
Always, bro. Thank you for being here.
We'll actually see you again next week
because, folks, we will be doing our
one-year anniversary stream. So, we will
see you again next week, my friend. Uh
definitely tune in for that folks
because uh the one-year stream is going
to be super fun. We're going to do some
hate mail. We're going to talk about um
some really big updates on things. Um so
definitely tune in for that. It'll be a
little bit more of a light-hearted fun
kickback stream uh with a number of
guests. So definitely tune in for that
next week. To close us out,
folks, I know that was a lot. Four
hours. I've talked about this before.
This is a marathon outlet. We do short
format content on Mondays, long format
content on Thursdays. We put the
timestamps in so you can easily come
back and reference. Utilize that.
Utilize that. Some of these things,
folks, require a deep dive. I said
tonight you were going to need strong
lungs because we were going to deep dive
or you can tell it's been late. We were
going to dive deep on this topic. And we
didn't even really get all the way
through everything that you could on
this specific topic. Maybe sometime
we'll dedicate a stream to specifically
just great controversy narrative
details.
But one note I want to leave you with.
We started with second Timothy.
Folks, the apostles did not have the
great controversy theme worldview.
Paul the apostle did not have the great
controversy theme when he penned second
Timothy.
Yet he told that young pastor,
a young pastor at the time,
that the scriptures were sufficient for
all doctrine and teaching.
Yet in the 1900s or 19th century, the
1800s,
now all of a sudden you have to have the
great controversy theme
to even understand scripture.
Paul didn't say anything about needing
scripture and and then this extra
biblical paradigm to actually understand
what's going on there.
They just sort of take this amorphic
character now
because our movement well we have a
prophetus she says so
no it's not working that way and when
you claim to have been given the theory
of everything remember folks theory of
everything.
Yeah, we're gonna scrutinize it.
If you're in Adventist leadership, we
are not slowing down on this platform.
We're going to keep doing stuff like
this. We got a lot of stuff planned. We
got a lot of stuff planned. We're going
to be making some announcements next
week. This thing is snowballing, folks.
This thing is growing. I I mean, I'm not
just huffing smoke on the internet,
folks.
We're not here for clicks.
We are in the sense that we want to
reach as many people as possible, but
we're not here because, oh, this is a
good opportunity to just try and garner
traction and become a e-le.
I don't give a rip about that.
I don't give a rip about that. I know
that this platform's flavor is not going
to be for everyone.
We're intense here.
I want Christians to understand.
This is not Christian.
I don't know any other way to say it.
Which means these people are deceived.
They're going to hell.
It's time to get active. They're in your
own backyard. Overlooked people group.
It's not all about third world
countries, folks. That's what so many
people think of when they think of
reaching people. Somewhere out there,
some some other people. No, your own
backyard.
We need to reach these people. That's
what we're doing here. So, if you're in
Adventist leadership, we are not slowing
down.
We're going to keep educating Christians
by proxy, educating Adventists, too, who
don't even know that they've been given
this worldview. People that leave this
movement that are completely confused
because they've taken this lens with
them, not understanding all of these
finer details. Yeah. Those of us that
have put the work in to be able to
connect these sorts of dots, we're going
to share that information with other
people.
It's not going to fly anymore.
We know the things to look for. We know
the questions to ask, etc. The old bait,
the old tactics, that what Ted Wilson
tried at annual council not going to
work anymore.
It's not going to work anymore.
We're on a mission here. We are going to
equip as many Christians as possible to
reach as many Seventh Day Adventists as
possible
and just watch the gospel just flourish.
Mark these sessions down, folks. Not cuz
I'm amazing. Not cuz answering Adventism
is something that God has to have. No.
Mark this this stuff down because we're
not playing games here.
They can say what they want. They can
make the claims that they want. They're
going to. We have a different mindset
here, folks. This isn't just, oh, it's
just a YouTube channel. It's just some
some person barking on the internet. No,
that's not what's going on here. Keep
thinking that. That's not what's going
on here. We're making big announcements
next week.
This was a long thing in the making. We
didn't start this platform hastily.
We picked this avenue because this is
the tradition I came out of. You had to
have the great controversy worldview to
be able to bridge the gap and do what
we're doing here. And by bridge the gap,
I mean demystify the fact that no,
there's actually a divide here. And you
have to be able to communicate that to
Christians to show them
essentially a peak behind the hand of
their cards
because they're not they're going to
bluff and try and tell you, "No, no, no.
We're just like you are.
It's not going to work. The SDA
apologists out there, they don't even
understand why we're doing what we're
doing. They think it's about them.
It's like, you don't get it, do you?
This is a Christian education outlet.
And it is working. It's working. We're
getting testimonies flooding in. So,
they can say what they want. They can
use these tired tactics. They can
continue trying. And and I'm saying this
mainly, folks, to let you know really
what the mission and and whatnot is
here. But be prepared. A day is coming
where they're going to run a hit piece
on and a PR campaign on answering
Adventism.
And they're going to use the same old
tired tactics that they have and it's
going to be embarrassing because this
thing's going to be moving at such a
pace and such a speed that it's going to
blast through that barrier and it's not
going to work
because the truth wins.
The gospel is undefeated.
It's not my gospel. It's not answering
Adventism's gospel.
This is Christ's gospel who CMBB just
got done talking about. He's ruling and
reigning. He's making all of his enemies
a foottool. This organization is an
enemy of the Lord Jesus Christ.
It's going to be made a foottool. Not
the people. There's going to be lots of
people that get called out of this thing
in the actual shaking
where God is actually calling people to
himself, out of this movement and
deception.
There's going to be lots of those people
that come to know freedom in Christ.
So, we aren't slowing down here. We got
a lot of stuff planned.
One-year anniversary stream is next
week. Highly suggest tuning in, folks.
It's not just going to be all fun and
games. We're gonna have some fun, but I
highly recommend that you tune in
because we're going to be talking about
some big updates.
We also have something happening next
week that I'll be reporting on after it
takes place, which is going to also be
talked about at that stream. So, please
show up. Adventists,
at some point, you got to get honest
with the facts.
I know there are people that watch this
channel who haven't said a word ever
that are SDA. I know some of you
got to make a choice. You got to make a
choice. It's time.
You can't have this system without all
of this other extra stuff here.
Don't say you just believe the Bible.
You don't just believe the Bible.
You can though. You You can though.
You can take the path of abandoning all
of that stuff and seeking to understand
what the author intended to communicate,
using your mind to glorify God, trusting
that he'll lead you, and he'll
oftentimes, more than likely, use the
church. You don't have to be fearful of
that.
And by that, I mean the great gifts that
God has given to the church down through
the centuries because Christianity is an
ancient faith.
You didn't crack some code in the 19th
century where everyone else was wrong
before you. Sorry, you didn't.
Christianity is an ancient faith. It's a
messy history. Yep, it is. And God has
been leading his people through all of
that.
So, if you're an Adventist, our call to
you is the same as your call to us. Come
out of her, my people. You think we're a
part of of the of Babylon,
but we think you're a part of her, Ellen
and her cult.
Come join us. There's actual good news
out there, folks. It's not Adventism.
Doesn't mean that they don't have themes
that are correct. Generally speaking,
oh, you don't believe there's a conflict
between good and evil?
Yeah, because that's all the great
controversy is, right?
Come join us.
Come join us. Until next time, as
always, God bless.
[Music]